so you can perfect
[Music]
what's up everybody wait [ __ ] [ __ ]
you i sure stumbled on my own intro
you know what keep that [ __ ] what's up
everybody dopes yolo here hope you're
having a dope ass day welcome back to
another episode of the dope as usual
podcast
today we have filmmaker matt alonso and
uh thank you so [ __ ] much for coming
i know it's a little
rough you got a damn flat tire on the
way in but yeah okay
gotta do what you got to do though we
got here thanks for making it no thank
you
like i'm [ __ ] done i'll see you
tomorrow absolutely not
i hate that [ __ ] absolutely so thank you
for thank you for still coming
even though they weren't going to let
you to come yeah they weren't trying to
let me the nail the nail you know
it was in there and i said you know what
[ __ ] it i'm riding out
[ __ ] this rim
yo i bro you ever broke like a tie rod
or an axle in your car
never i did one time and uh it was
bouncing like hydraulics down the street
bro it was so scary it was i guess so i
mean
it was a dodge intrepid and it didn't
look natural
but i didn't see you hopping i was smoke
coming out the car about to get pulled
over i was it was all bad i was
delivering pizza at the time hey but you
think you pulled over and i made it so
exactly so thank you so much for showing
up thank you for coming um
i'm very interested man this is what
this is what i do like
marty and i both as soon as you say so
check this out go oh [ __ ]
interesting [ __ ] yeah i can't wait to
hear it so for everyone out there that
doesn't know what you do you're a
filmmaker
yep primarily do music videos or actual
features
uh i haven't done a feature yet but i've
i studied narrative and that was
you know that's the goal um music videos
just kind of stumbled
uh stumbled upon my uh my path and i
decided just to
attack it full force and for whatever
reason that seems to be what everybody
um really likes as far as social media
wise i mean i
i did a show with mark cuban two likes
you know he put a music video
and it's always though so it is what it
is you know what i mean um i've done
pretty much
all genres of of content and then i was
assigned to icm as a feature film
director for about four years
wow um they wrapped me as a feature film
director so
uh you know i've had my how'd you get
how did you get into i mean
you said that was the end goal so
music videos weren't you're like you
know what i'm gonna be a music video
director first
it was feature film so you were thinking
first yeah i mean i went to film school
um that was one of my questions yeah
yeah i went to film school
i i was i was editing and filming when i
was like six
seven years old years old yeah yeah
okay my parents had me really young like
kind of like your story so my mom and my
dad were like 17 they didn't even know
each other they just
hey what's up hooked up one night and
then hey i'm pregnant
oh damn and my and both my parents came
from broken homes so my parents
my dad was like hey i don't know you but
i'm gonna learn to love you we're gonna
have this baby
are they still together uh no but in 35
years 30 years
so that's commitment yeah i know right
wow so i had a whole different outlook
on life just like
just having that sort of you know
foundation yeah you know and
they were they were both kids so my dad
just wanted to
to document all of our experiences all
the good and the bad
so he had a camera in my face and i
hated it i hated it
and eventually he started showing me on
tv like hey look matt you're dancing and
i'm like okay
you plug it into the tv and so i saw
that and i think i saw how
the tv or the camera created or gave
emotions like it made people happy and
so i wanted i wanted that you know and
then i learned
i can make people cry you can make
people feel a certain way
really young and so that was just what i
did i did that and played football
you sound like me that's what i was
saying i was listening to your story i'm
like
oh yeah and then i don't speak spanish
i've been to mexico they don't like i
mean they
go like this stiff arm your ass the
second you walk in
yeah exactly so i don't i don't know how
much like
i don't know what the shade is that i
can go like you know what i mean i think
i'm pretty pretty much the
the max that's it that's as far as you
could go
and they're like uh and they speak to me
i'm like i i don't you know
i'm sorry i'm from santa barbara i'm
like i'm from santa barbara i have surf
i don't even eat onions they just do my
pasta i don't eat
onions do you have any kids no i got no
kids i know they're like you are
[ __ ] you're 16 you have a family
i know
[ __ ] you i'm in school that's why i was
listening to your story i was like okay
yeah we
got a few things in common oh [ __ ] way
more than i thought
so you started your dad had the camera
in your face and you
just got accustomed to liking this [ __ ]
yeah i mean i just saw the way that it
would make them smile
and so i realized oh i can you know make
my parents happy with this thing
and then make my friends happy and make
other people happy or sad and then i
just realized like oh i can pretty much
manipulate people's feelings with this
box
and i would plug two vcrs in and
just do it like that what the [ __ ] as a
child
yeah that is badass remember the old uh
rewind tapes i never had one of those no
you had to sit there and watch the whole
movie in reverse now we would stop and
then
it would rewind but we i never had like
you could take it out and then put it
into a separate things
yeah i remember it was like a [ __ ]
fake car we had yeah i
that's how you started you've been doing
it ever since yeah yeah i mean i was
playing football and then
obviously 5-1 on a good day like i
wasn't going anywhere
so i graduated and i didn't really have
anything else to do and
and i i couldn't afford to go to film
school my parents were like
sorry you're out of luck yeah so i went
to city college and worked at the gap
nice and i worked for the city of santa
barbara that's what i'm from carpenter
santa barbara so i was cleaning parking
lots in the morning going to school and
then going to the gap
driving back to ventura which is like an
hour away every single day
[ __ ] it well my buddy yeah [ __ ] it i
mean i i didn't make it work yeah
not really i mean that's pretty much
ditching class eventually no i'm saying
you got to make it work for your
like what you what you want to do i
didn't know what i wanted to do at that
at that so filming was in your life but
it wasn't your primary focus yet no
no no i mean i was out i was like well i
was out just looking at women just i was
in the mix
you know what i mean i was popping at
that moment i was like oh no
you know what i mean i know yeah yeah
yeah i mean i still i was the film
i was like the video guy at my high
school like oh i was always with the
camera but
when i graduated it was kind of like
maybe i have a camera yeah maybe i'll do
some weddings and and you know i did my
first music video
it was let's not even talk about that
one but uh
but yeah so my one of my buddies who was
a young friend
of mine uh i got him into film because i
got all my friends in the film i'm
talking like i played football so i had
all the
cool kids yeah so i'd get these like
gangster dudes these like
you know really you know big dudes to to
do whatever in my scripts like i would
just have them
oh you were writing [ __ ] out already
yeah oh yeah yeah i mean it was trash
but but you took it serious
as much as a hobby can be yeah okay yeah
we had like
we we just did a bunch of like like
smoking uh
you know like we would smoke and then
we'd fall asleep on the couch disappear
and then we
you know we'd pop up in the forest and
we'd be like karate sounds like me when
i first started yeah
that's what i was that's exactly what i
was doing yeah absolutely love
it hilarious i still have all my tapes
too i have everything oh man that's so
funny everything
bro yeah and that's that's the one part
like i really like i really i'm really
thankful that i did i saw my dad
being very organized with all his tapes
because i have all his tapes so he's
filming like every birthday party
everything oh man he filmed when i when
i got this scar
and he felt bad he actually went home
and deleted that
because it felt like that because it
well because we were wrestling and i
just happened to do
and he was laughing and it was just
blood and then i was a little guy and so
he came back
when i was getting stitched up he
deleted it you didn't tell me until we
leave years
that's tight you should have kept that
that's what i told him he was like nah
man i felt so guilty i had to go home i
just i had a pit in my stomach and i was
like damn
how old were you little i was like five
or six oh yeah i would erase that [ __ ] i
was like hey dad and i just i tried to
like juke him and i just went
boom right into the door but um i saw
him he was really organized with all his
tapes and so obviously i mimicked him
and so i was organized with all my tapes
and i have everything i mean every film
school
project high school middle school and
elementary everything love it
it's awesome that's very [ __ ] cool
that's awesome so but that my friend
ended up going to the film school that i
wanted to go to
he was you know he was a little bit
wealthier than i was and uh
he got him into it yeah yeah yeah he was
but he was lazy
and uh he was just we were all just
owners at that point
but i started doing all his projects so
he took my dad aside and he was like yo
your son's getting a's on my projects
you need to figure out a way to get him
to this
in close school because what is he gonna
do what you know what are we going to do
it's it's i come from a small town so i
was like
he's going to work at the gap forever so
yeah they so so you went to school right
after high school you went to film
school
no that i took a year i took a year to
do to work at the gap
and go oh this is in between yeah so i
was done at the gap and i'm at
santa barbara city college which if
anybody knows that campus it's beautiful
it's right on the beach so yeah you know
i mean no literally
on the beach you're never in class so
yeah i wouldn't be
yeah so it was like that was it that was
i mean that was did you finish like
school
i mean i finished film school oh so uh
not the santa's barber oh hell i didn't
even finish like two
like two weeks of class man you are me
yeah i just talked i went to
jc for five years i never graduated
i was just talking about it i just sold
drugs so i was like i gotta leave class
someone needs a sec
you're out i'm out that's my excuse like
i need to pay my rent
i'm out so then why why'd you keep going
back because i'd get dropped because i
missed so many classes and i go no i'm
finishing
i'm going back next semester same [ __ ]
three months in two months in three
months in
what were you studying business degree i
guess
i was just trying to knock out all my
gas like a general
i got one class left and i'll be done
but i'm [ __ ] over that [ __ ] oh no
take that
i know everybody tells me the same thing
it was an update i know i was thinking
about just paying somebody like yo just
take online class for me say or me
thanks
hey anybody out there i mean that
wouldn't even be bad man i know i'll
just defraud the government get my
[ __ ]
ga or aaa or whatever with it
general admissions general admission
they had something like that like
associates it's a associate's degree but
the g it was
general like the general class generally
you got to take these certain
[ __ ] classes to even get your aaa
and i remember
what would you say general admission i
can't remember
so that's for like six flags yes
but it's the general ed education right
no there's like uh
like six core classes you gotta take in
college yeah gen ed's
that's probably what i'm pretty sure
that's what it is i don't know that was
i know
you know i didn't pay attention enough
to know
i've heard that i was about to graduate
they're like what school do you want to
go to i gotta go
i mean you were that you were that guy
you were the you were the main one
was wheat yeah um you were up there i
had
the guy i got it from and there was like
two other dudes and probably some cartel
people in town that did it bigger but as
far as the school
oh in school um college i sold to weed
to nobody
[ __ ] that because i don't know them high
school i toured the [ __ ] up
after college when i was out that's why
i would leave so much because i was
selling so much weed
[ __ ] it yeah you would have killed it at
film school like our school was like
all these kids who were art artists oh
they just
i'm just i keep to myself so much if i
don't know people so that's why i never
got
more i have a friend named michael he
went to the
to the uc got a four-year degree didn't
care what he got because he was just
selling weed to everybody
but brick we trash we didn't taxing the
out of town or kids hey they don't care
about two houses during school
and uh two houses one of vegas one
merced
wow off of office shout out to him
baller
today he graduated we're all drinking
congratulations man and i'm like why do
you look sad
and he goes all my customers are gone
and then went back and got another uh
another uh
degree in spanish [ __ ] he really spoke
spanish i'm just gonna degree in spanish
and tax people seem to school for eight
years just to sell weed that's good
make that money dude he's one of the
smartest people i know only 21 year old
with a [ __ ] own house
and no spanish and no spanish folks on
it man
better than us i had people to teach me
i just didn't give a [ __ ] after a while
man
then i went to mexico and then i went i
should have just paid attention dreams
shattered
dude going crazy going to mexico's crazy
you don't speak spanish
exactly when you're when you're around
it's just like i almost feel like
they don't spit in my stuff oh they
definitely do they definitely
they threw my passport like they threw
my passport just back to you
wait no they didn't throw back to me
they just go get it
where when i went there i was no i mean
like where were you like at a hotel
i don't even remember i must been eight
no no i must have been 18 or 19. i don't
remember exactly where we were
my friend's family they all spoke
spanish everyone spoke spanish and
he was talking and he just i don't know
what he was saying and i was like no
i don't i don't know and then i sound
like even more white yeah i'm the same
here
go get it i mean he didn't like but he
didn't hand it to me
oh hell no i had to fight mexico
yeah it's all bad because then you don't
even know if they're calling the truce
what if they're calling the truce and
you can't even understand
that's what i say all the time like i
know you're gonna jump me i know
something's wrong
it's all the spanish i know man that's
it other than that
i don't know i took two years of spanish
too
and you know how i passed i made spanish
videos
you just do with the camera's best yeah
and my mom would help me and she'd be
like hola and i'd be like hola
and we were just and that was it like
it's both spanish no i'm
just my mom that's why i didn't learn
because my mom would be teaching me when
i was younger and my dad would be like
what are you saying to him teach me
teach me too she's like i ain't trying
to repeat myself
is your dad mexican too he's he's dark
like me but he's his
his lineage is from like arizona and
spain so it's not really spanish but my
mom's
my mom's second generation are first
generation so
from jalisco so she was like fluent but
my dad would be like what are you saying
what are you telling him and my mom was
like nah i'm over this
my dad uh remarried and she's from
mexico
so when they had more kids i have little
brothers and sisters now
when they pissed me off when i was
younger i'm like yo you better knock it
off i'm over 18. like i can't do [ __ ] to
you
and then they'd run and tell their mom
[ __ ] in spanish and be
lying their asses off about what i did
and i go
what are you saying what do you say
little kid [ __ ] you
it's like i'm trapped you believe i'm a
[ __ ] abuser now oh absolutely
absolutely you're going to believe your
kid and all myself it's the worst thing
it's the
worst that's the worst i i had a my best
friend
his family spoke spanish and the grandma
she was really old but she'd call me
burro i don't know exactly i haven't
looked it up but i don't i don't believe
it means donkey
i don't believe i don't believe it means
uh handsome but she would just like
and she would just laugh just constantly
at me and i was just like
okay oh my god that's [ __ ] up she's
kind of cool though
that's kind of a cool little grandma it
is what you try to talk [ __ ] to somebody
yeah
it's kind of cool you know she's
throwing jabs
[ __ ] it dude i mean i don't give a [ __ ]
if i have to move to mexico i'll learn
right
i'll learn today do you like mexican
food though like yeah it's cool
you like onions and stuff yeah you know
i ate all vegetables basically
but i can't eat hot [ __ ] my dad used to
try to pay me to eat salsa
but now that i'm older whatever i don't
give a [ __ ] yeah i can't eat hot either
no he'll know but yeah mexico if you for
everyone at home if you're brown don't
go to mexico you don't speak spanish hey
i still have my
shunned i still have my spanish videos
from spanish class
hilarious that's cool man that's
hilarious it's so bad that's like one of
those things when you're like 15 you
make
a compilation of your life who can say
that
very rare yeah i mean no extremely rare
you know
really rare that my dad started it and i
kind of just carried that one
yeah wow did you have your birth no
really no he wasn't because we didn't
have money like that you know
they were 17 living in a hotel that's
right that's cleaning the cars
mad mad young mad young yeah my mom and
dad are like 18 years
know each other do they know did they
know each other though yeah they were
dating my sister's a year and a half
older than me
so they had her in 15 and 17. and then
had me the next year like it's a good
[ __ ] move
like you know we're doing so well living
in our parents let's make another one
absolutely
absolutely press go on that for real
like i'm a sophomore
time to have another kid run that back
[ __ ] that [ __ ] oh my god dude yeah it's
a different time you know
we're sad stuck in that everybody has i
was just talking about it we have the
highest
underage uh teen pregnancy in the
country for like five years straight
really
it's crazy and where is that at i mean i
know you said the middle of merced is
right by fresno you know we're fresno
i'm from stockton i was born in stockton
for real yeah my parents because my dad
both my parents were like
juvenile kids like they were in juvenile
hall and stuff so they just had to go up
they had to leave santa barbara for a
little bit and uh they had me there and
then they
really stockton is an hour and ten from
merced okay so then you know it's right
off the 99. look at that yeah it's
between modesto and fresno
we might be brothers we're at the church
we're [ __ ] related somehow we [ __ ]
we showed the same hotel
when you were born that's crazy you're
in stockton
i've never been there like i mean i've
been there
when i was like six months so oh [ __ ] so
you've been santa barbara the whole time
carpenter but santa barbara yeah what'd
you call it carpinteria which is like i
heard that a little bit
uh south of santa barbara it has like
two stoplights i had like maybe 50 kids
in my graduating class
oh yeah you're like there's a lot of
places in merce i mean in a in
california like
like how does it not [ __ ] have people
yeah you're 20 minutes from a major city
and you guys live by yourself
even when i heard yeah i heard you i
heard the name and i'm like do i know
that it doesn't ring a bell
it's one of those it doesn't ring a bell
yeah it's it's kind of it's like a farm
agriculture meth town
so yeah it's it's really crazy right
like and there's nothing to do and
murder
like because because the parents the
parents are out at the
you know the fields yeah and so the kids
have run
reckless [ __ ] create gangs yeah i
mean that's that's what my dad was
telling me that's all it is
lack of parental control lack of getting
punched in your [ __ ] face will make
you start a gang
well that's i mean that's then we have
gangs everywhere which is what we do we
just have soft gangs
the other ones you know what i mean no
dude that's
you grew up in a town like i did then
that's crazy how was growing up there
uh santa barbara well yeah like if
you're beautiful if you're
okay but if you're out there filming and
that's your thing you play football were
you running the [ __ ]
running around doing crazy [ __ ] dude
crazy i mean i was wild i was homecoming
king and i was like
oh no homecoming to like ditching like i
don't i almost didn't graduate because i
i had
missed so much school yeah i had to go
to my football coach and be like please
sign my because he was a history teacher
i'm like please sign this that i was in
this class that i wasn't
did you do it yeah what a badass i still
have nightmares about that sometimes
wake up
we're just yo we're very much alike i
have [ __ ] straight nightmares that i
walk into school and i'm three months
late
and i go wait i got all fs i don't even
have time to [ __ ] save this
and that was it it's like i'm back in
10th grade oh man it's
the [ __ ] worst bro it is but it was
the best though like a lot of you know
and i got a lot of my crazy [ __ ] out by
the time i was 19 20 by the time i was
21 i was like
you were on this end of school and i was
on this end because like i knew all the
football i used to play football too but
i quit
my coach is a [ __ ] piece [ __ ] and
all the cool kids and all those fools
like i know them and i was like yeah i'm
gonna just go do drugs
i'll see you but we were the same like
we were all yeah we said i separated it
was very separate
and our in our in our town we were the
coolest you're so small like yo i'm a
athlete a truck headache yeah pretty
much absolutely everybody has to play
the role
yeah everyone i mean that's what it was
i mean it's kind of like a varsity blues
type like
that's what small towns are like yeah
yeah and we won cif so we were just like
free from oh so you're this
you're these guys free for all free for
offerings you're wearing high socks and
flip-flops
and slides yeah i definitely was wearing
slides i mean i'm surprised they're
coming back i'm like they have a bunch
of those
yeah i know i you described me yourself
perfectly
and you were homecoming oh come on man
you were that guy i mean i was just i
was wild i was just a class clown just
off just i mean i was always wild as a
kid just
doing stupid [ __ ] oh i mean the
stupidest you could possibly imagine
besides like
violent stuff you know i mean just like
were you getting into trouble
uh luckily luckily no because people let
us go
because you were the football kids yeah
what positions you play
running back linebacker no [ __ ] you are
the homecoming king
yeah but not like that like i was more
good but i was more i was more of just
the class clown
just the the raw rock guy i was the guy
starting [ __ ] oh you're looking at it
hey hey
like you know i ain't gonna fight fight
him yeah i would just i mean i was just
i mean i begin
i begin [ __ ] going like i don't know it
was instigate ness is what i hear right
here through the roof
like i have instigator on the back of my
neck oh yeah absolutely i was leading
the rallies and i was just i mean i was
just loud i was just yeah dude that's
cool
i always saw those those kids in school
and i go
it's just not me i just i talk a lot
when i know you
other than that like uh i don't want to
talk i just stabbed
myself i got parties i'm in the back
smoking weed everybody's chilling
hey that was me yeah in the back we were
in the back but we were doing something
else and it was just like we were so
young
at that time that we just like we just
didn't the town has nothing there has
two stoplights so it's like
what do you do what would you drugs have
kids yeah and we weren't you know
yeah we weren't doing that the other the
latter
i'm telling you but it's just it's just
a small town yeah it is what it is and
it was a beautiful town it was right on
the beach it's
it's you know this is you know i'm two
miles away from where oprah lives
oh so oh i'm like that oh it's beautiful
i mean beautiful never been
beautiful i mean if you're ever going
that way santa barbara there's a little
town you'll see or a gas station you'll
see just pull off
that's where i grew up yeah yeah behind
that guest absolutely you see the beach
right there i mean it's absolutely
i mean it's it's it's a great place to
grow up
at least you had some cool [ __ ] as a kid
absolutely that's cool man yeah
yeah you know yeah so growing up is dope
you basically got your start because
your
dad my parents both of my parents very
cool
yeah they were like yo uh stop [ __ ]
up and uh
you know own up and we're gonna
refinance the house and
send you to school yeah that's how you
got to film school yeah grow the [ __ ] up
nice so they sent you to film school and
from there
did you already know or did was film
school
did it help you 100 nice bro i was the
guy
i was like oh my god i got it i didn't
even know cameras had lenses
uh you know you're over the [ __ ]
because back in those days the
goonies camcorder well i mean the dbxa
just came out
so and that was the first 24 frames
camera
so before that it was just like a little
sony you know before that was a
you know big one on the show a mini yeah
well i have i still have mine
damn yeah that's cool this one pops out
dude yeah absolutely i didn't even know
i was like a lens and all this stuff
they made us take stills for the first
like eight months nine months and then i
realized like
light meter and just how to tell stories
in like five pictures i mean i realized
like yo
i don't know oh like narrative and like
dialogue and stuff is that what they
were
there yeah i mean yeah it was a
three-year va program and it was like it
was amazing
it was amazing you know so um the first
year i mean it's all narrative-based
you can choose your track commercial
music video whatever you kind of want to
do
i chose narrative because it kind of
encompassed everything like obviously
you can break off and do these things if
you learn
the story structure and all that stuff
so so that's what i did i just wanted to
be an editor at first though
like first year and then i started
making people's [ __ ] look really good
that sucked and i was like i introduced
myself
yeah what am i doing i'm like what am i
doing i'm over here ghost writing
sitting in the room just like
i'm like you know i got to get out of
this [ __ ] room so so yes you know
that's what i started doing and uh
and by by the time i graduate well by my
senior year which was like you know my
third year i was already doing
internships in la and i was pretty much
i was pretty much working for a record
company really
yeah so you graduate and immediately get
work i
moved the day i graduated moved to santa
monica and uh
the guy the company ended up releasing
all their staff and just just
was like all right you're the head of
production now right out of school
yeah it was actually cheaper for them to
pay me on salary than it was
to pay individual people and to pay me
because i was i was editing on two
computers so i was charging them for two
hours every hour
yeah what
should i be like i mean that'll be
rendering or exporting or whatever
on the next [ __ ] yeah back then you had
to you know you had to put your tape in
and then actually play it you know
yo you're a hustling [ __ ] man
yeah that is badass
so the you move the day yeah you
graduate you get a job they fire
everyone
what is this place uh it was so the so
the actual company was
um um a like a
colon cleanse it was this guy it was
this white guy he got he he bought
this patent or bought this um this thing
from from somebody who
it was um it was called irwin naturals i
mean you know
it's all documented he could check my
receipts no but uh so so he bought he
bought this office and he would do
infomercials
he made millions like i'll clean your
you know
yeah for he made millions of dollars
millions i mean this is back
what slap chopping [ __ ] was without
money like 2007
2007. so so then he so then he had a
side he had a side girl who was
you know that him and his wife and the
side girl would have lunch together and
and and she was so he had it made his
whole life oh yeah and she
and she was black he was white but he
would come in sometimes with chains on
and stuff like
in like a beanie and he was like really
kind of like not
that style yeah and then he would he's
like i'm starting a label so he started
a label
record music yeah because because the
girl that he you know the side girl
wanted him to sign two or three of her
friends
from high school this one got played
so he ended up he ended up signing then
he's like you know what i want to do
i want to do a double album for every
artist on my on my
label and i want to shoot every music
video for every single song oh
he's ambitious yeah and then he wanted
to package it as a infomercial
the music and the music videos and the
artists he was going to sell
you know we started making infomercials
for these things she's not dumb
one of the other groups was like a black
skateboarding group and at that time
wayne hadn't even started skateboarding
it was like
it just wasn't but he was ahead of his
time i gotta give him credit you know
but none of these kids knew how to
skateboard
jamaican bobsled team shout out to the
wood pushers man but you know i just you
know it was what it was and i was i was
getting paid and
and you know i was making a lot of money
you know but the money i mean i never
got into this
for the money you know what i mean of
course not as soon as you can go cool
keep paying me that [ __ ]
yeah for a little bit and then you get
to a point where you're like okay
there's nobody here teaching me anything
this guy's sitting next to me
you know and then eventually the the you
know the head of his other company
started telling me your body spent two
three million dollars bro
like if you don't start recouping you're
done so they were done so they're like
yo we're cutting you off until you start
making more money back okay
so then i started doing infomercials and
i was writing these like uh
you know i was making news infomercials
so instead of you thinking it was an
infomercial it looked like the news
hi we're here reporting live you're
smart
and so and so that but then i'm like
what am i doing clicks online
like wait i'm watching oh yeah i mean
they're smart youtube wasn't even really
out like that at that time
so you know but the you know one one
time he
he put makeup on his face but he didn't
put makeup on his his neck just clear
so he wanted me to yeah go in there and
frame by frame and that's when i just
kind of lost it oh
hell no yeah so like worth the amount of
money i called my dad and i was like
dad what do i do i was kind of i mean i
was i was pretty like pretty
flustered hysterical basically yeah but
i mean i'm painting this guy's neck
yeah he's sitting next to me i'm like i
don't really care how much money this is
but i didn't know what to do because
like you know you figure go get go to
college get a job
yeah that's what you're supposed to do
my dad's like uh are you growing as a
man i said no
you're growing as an artist i said no no
he's like all right then you know what
to do so i was like all right grab my
bag and i just walked out
good [ __ ] yep that's the last day you
went yep
so what'd you do you're jobless uh car
got repossessed got kicked out of my
apartment
if you don't believe in it that much
it's [ __ ] worth it and i did and the
thing was like
my vision was already there i already
saw where i was gonna go and i knew that
it wasn't gonna be through this avenue
so i don't i don't recommend it
you know what i mean it definitely was a
split like a split second decision that
you know hindsight i still would make
the same decision but if it
came now i probably you know i would
have to look at things and look at get a
different job
now you're an adult basically yeah with
experience life experience yeah
absolutely you know still
wants a car replacement luckily i mean
you know that was what it was i was just
like here
i'm saying you don't want to do that
[ __ ] like not going to no that's why you
buy a used car
that's the you know that's this the life
hack
you can't get a used car repossessed i
mean you know cars ain't there's
there's absolutely no like benefit in
buying a brand new car you know so not
at all
uh you learn that when you make a little
bit of money you know what i mean
certain things you know i'm looking at a
2019 car that i really love right
now that's what i'm saying the
appreciation is a house
i just i just shot with uh d smoke the
rapper like and uh oh dee
smoke he's from the netflix thing at the
yeah come on why do i know that he just
used up for a grammy i i know that name
i know the name he's got dreads right
yeah yeah he got dressed and
he's kind of southern he's from l.a he
looks like he's from the south yeah he
looks like
himself he's dope he's really cool i've
only heard a couple of his songs
oh yes that's the guy that's the guy
yeah so i was thinking of somebody else
but i have seen this full before but you
think like you know like
i don't think like this but a lot of
people do you know and uh
you know oh looking for a car or
whatever and then he just shows up in
his honda
and it's like cool good no i know i like
for me it's like
i i appreciate stuff like that you know
of course i've seen i've seen the the
wide spectrum of uh everything you could
possibly have i'm sure you've seen a lot
of people
and i brought my dad and i brought my
dad to all my videos like a lot of my
videos and my mom and they were just
like
what is going on because they don't
unders they don't know everything's
rented and fake and
the houses and theirs and they're like
well for every music video yeah he's
like where is he for real
they're like where'd he go with this
change my dad's like where's he going
with his change he got his chains i'm
like dad that's not his chains
why are you taking his car is that just
is that his is that his assistant i'm
like no that's the car owner we rented
it
oh no and my streams just all got
shattered right now
all of it's fake yeah yeah you hesitated
for a long time means and
100 is fake oh yeah now these
[ __ ] own chains
so my job my job as a video director or
just
my job as a filmmaker director content
creator is to manipulate the audience's
perspective absolutely in whatever way
that the client asks me to
and that's the formula that's like
cooking like i'm turning this into that
that's what your [ __ ] is like but you
don't have to know what's in between you
gotta make sure you're entertained but
when it was
when you look at it from that sort of
perspective you know and i try to teach
this to the younger filmmakers it just
really kind of
gives you a lot of clarity like you
don't need to worry about the jib arm or
this the red camera or these certain
things that a lot of these people get
caught up in
a lot of the newer school ones with you
know instagram and such like
but it's like dude if you can get from
point a to point b without any of that
then
great if you need some of that great but
just understand what your actual mission
is you know
and so that's a really good way to put
it yeah it's super good way to put it
actually i think
it's better explained in that short ass
sentence than most people
like seminars and [ __ ] you're trying to
manipulate who's watching
and change their perspective that's
[ __ ] awesome i love it it's always i
love it you know it's basically
no different than a poster or a you know
you know an ad that you see or
anything you know what i mean it's all
the same it's all the same thing you
know yeah i just don't
some of my some of the kids that i went
to film school with or i was around
earlier were just like
they thought we were saving lives and
i'm just like
i love what i do i mean i work 18 hours
a day non-stop for 10 15 years but like
let's just be making entertainment yeah
just be honest about what it is you know
what i mean and then be good at what it
is
and not so you know up in the clouds you
know so yeah of course
but i try i try to teach that it just
doesn't it doesn't it doesn't come off
the tongue right like it just you know
it it takes time man and plus a lot of
this what you do
is it's experiencing time and you know i
mean like you can go to school for
[ __ ] eight years
and come out and be like well i know how
to use it all but i can't get a good
shot to save my [ __ ] life
well but they they're not even worried
about that so much now and i look to
this because i never had anybody to
mentor me
as coming up i was always kind of the
head guy which is unfortunate
but you know a lot of these guys that
hit me up or you know kids that i talk
to because i want to i want to be able
to give back and help out
yeah and uh the questions that they ask
me are just about technical hey what's
the
you know the the you know 8k or 12k or
27k and i'm just like dude
that is pointless to me you know but it
just seems to be where their heads at so
that excites them or transitions or you
know
some lut or something as opposed to like
yo like what did
what are you actually doing do you want
to get more jobs they're blurring the
line of
how [ __ ] clean it is versus you know
this has no context
not even no context it's just nothing i
i tell them i in my class i was like yo
it doesn't matter how big
a piece it is just a bigger piece of
[ __ ] like
like what's the point it's so [ __ ]
true like yo my camera's 8k
but nobody cares dude nobody cares
you're trash you know what i mean
and it's not even so much that because
like you know your clients
or the people who are you know watching
your con they don't understand any of
this
consciously it's all subconscious and
they they either know like you you know
what you're doing or you don't you know
what i mean they don't really care with
the camera no client ever asked me hey
yeah no one ever came
what are you filming in i mean it's like
some you know passer buyers you know
what i mean hey
i have a jbc at home what is that you
know like that oh you always get that
yeah but i mean
as far as as far as you know everybody
else you know what i mean and then
it's like you know it's a i i looked at
your website
and basically you just summed it up i
watched a little
little clip of the game saying i didn't
read the treatment i just walked in and
i know he's gonna kill it
i don't know the concept i ain't read
the treatment um mad alonzo ever since
we did doughboys martians versus goblins
celebration
like that's my director is my go-to
director and uh he writes these
treatments and i just show up at the
video and it always turns out cool man
but that's you got to trust your team so
sick yeah that's the that's the
confidence like i walk and go marty's
got it
sit down absolutely no it's gonna get
edited because he's got it
absolutely yeah dude that's like the
confidence everyone should have in you
when you're doing your job
for everyone out there people should
know that when they say your name go oh
[ __ ] awesome
sick thank you yeah yeah yeah and it's
just it's just understanding what your
job is
you're a brand no matter how hard you
think you're not you are a brand
absolutely i'm a brand but i'm also they
also i'm also
uh given a brand your brand or games
brand
literally in my hands to he's trusting
me to actually
you know get results and to and to you
know do whatever it is that he's you
know hey i want to touch this audience
or i want i want to hit my own audience
to buy this out whatever it is right
yeah
that's i mean that's on my shoulders
like an established brand and i don't
think too many filmmakers or content
creators actually understand it yeah you
have to soak it in
in the terms of i'm filming avalovine
i'm not going to have her throwing money
but see that's the thing is that they
they have an idea a lot of them will
have an idea i want to have her i'm
going to have
somebody upside down in 16 millimeter
with flashing lights and avril lavigne
comes across the desk and that's who's
going to get that treatment
and it's that's what i'm trying to teach
them is like you know understand
everybody's
because they want to do it you know it's
like making beats you're like yo
this is going to be good for everyone
that walks in like nah bro yeah get the
person in
and talk just you know you wouldn't say
the same thing that you would send to
miley cyrus to d smoke you know what i
mean
but they do and that's why music videos
are kind of
different i guess you would say now i've
seen some really good ones and i've seen
some very
boring ones lately yeah i mean it just
depends on how much you like the artist
i think
i mean uh to me i've always said it a
really good song can go everywhere but a
really good song with a good music video
is classic
absolutely absolutely it's true no it is
it is and and
with all the psychology behind music and
the science that you know it brings up
memories and all these things
in our you know in our brains if the
visual is attached to that then i mean
you're synonymous with somebody's like
first kiss or whatever for the rest of
their life so
and that's what i've noticed a lot when
i get because now like these
10 12 year olds are like man i remember
listening to you i'm you know the
camp i went to in third grade i'm like
whoa whoa watching your video i'm like
oh man but i'm still with them like that
you know what i mean yeah of course and
that's cool
you know because the songs were really
big the videos were really big and then
they attached some sort of
life-changing moment or you know i
remember when when i first heard [ __ ]
thong song and saw the video
i remember these things because mtv used
to be the [ __ ]
[ __ ] and these premiere videos and then
the world premiere come on with a little
world premiere
like oh [ __ ] but there was some time
like yeah because we used to uh
tape them dude right yeah you should
tape that [ __ ] yup
like oh commercial [ __ ] [ __ ] is
commercial did you have blank tapes or
did you like shapes
okay and we would and we would get like
one blank tape like are you done with
this oh yeah let's
record it yeah yeah my grandpa table all
the niner games so
i'm like i'm gonna sneak one of these
why would you take the niner game
because he worked every day
he was a die hard all right yeah i
didn't miss it always
yeah at least he didn't tape so what i
did is we just taped over all our movies
we just put the tape on the actual
little you know the little square that
you that would be taken out yeah you
could do that [ __ ] oh yeah disney movies
were a wrap
oh hell no i didn't i wouldn't have
never bought a blanket
like you know you know the like the old
cassette tapes there was those two
little holes on the top
yes so if you bought it like a one that
was a recordable it it actually had like
it didn't have the indentions and if you
wanted it to be so that you couldn't
press record you just cracked those
little things
but if you if you got a tape that was
like crisscross an actual tape you could
just tape over the
little indentions and now it's a
recordable get the [ __ ] same thing
for videos
so i'm not technical i'm so trashed with
that [ __ ] i have no idea how i i
like a lot of stuff i learned when i was
a little kid i have no idea how i did
like how i learned it but
so you're sitting i know it's going
straight back but
you associated how these videos and this
is making your parents laugh and making
people laugh what was the turning point
is there something you remember watching
and you saw go
i kind of like filming or was it just a
phase of your life i mean it was
my whole life you know what i mean and
obviously i think when your parents
um as a young kid you know what i mean
understanding like psychology now
because psychology
plays such a huge part in filmmaking i
study psychology
heavily but you know being able to make
my parents
happy or you know please them you know i
guess probably the better word
um was was motivating for me as a
five-year-old kid
yeah you know what happened of course
hey look at that reaction
look at me you know what i mean so so
then i mean obviously having that sort
of you know
reward dangle then it was just a
motivating factor so it was always
it was always there but then i realized
you know with
this visual i can do these things i'm
manipulating same thing like i said
earlier you know so
i learned that in some sense early on
and then i learned what stories were
actually
for like why humans develop stories or
why they tell stories and it's
for you for us to learn something from
these other people so that we don't have
to go through it
yeah so it's just it's all there you
know what i mean and i just it was
fascinating to me
that's so sick man so you go from a
little kid you quit your job
then you get your [ __ ] repossessed
that's where we're at right now yeah
so remember guys you can [ __ ] up oh yeah
and still come back strong and i still
and i still [ __ ] up but plenty of
times after that yeah it's it's it's a
wrong process
yeah like oh i [ __ ] up this one time
like i can never show my face like
you have to the thing is that the things
that you have to [ __ ] up to be able to
to understand like if you're not [ __ ]
up you're not going to be successful
because that means
you're inside your box your comfort zone
yeah you're just chilling you know what
i mean nothing's
and you can still [ __ ] up in there yeah
that's i [ __ ] do so so it's like if
you're gonna if you're gonna [ __ ] up
which we all are it's inevitable why not
just do it
for you know a higher risk like why not
like
you know higher reward i guess some more
throw some more
you know just go all in [ __ ] it yeah
dude you know what i mean so of course
so yeah where were we at i was uh oh i
quit my job meeting top ramen
[ __ ] your back you're back to it back to
college life again basically not even
bro because college i was living with my
parents i was like oh
[ __ ] and i was like you i was moving
weight i was moving weight on the
compound so i was like
i mean you know like because i was the
only guy who was from
the town like my film school was like 10
10 miles away from my home my hometown
so
oh so once you get there go i have weed
all you have to do is smell like we
made money oh yeah i remember those
walking to the party the only reason i
go to party is selling to people
absolutely and and our
our film school like was like uh each
class was like 30 dudes to one girl
i just had to say that because it was
just so it was so bad oh you had to say
that's your
and that's your college yeah oh yeah
and your how would you call it cooper
what or uh it
was just town called carpentery
carpenter but my film school was it was
in
ventura it was called brooks institute
of photography it was on the erin
brockovich set which they had a whole
like you know but when i was in high
school you know i was playing varsity
and stuff so i was going to ucsb which
was the
uh the the university of santa barbara
college and i was partying out there i i
love vista i don't know if you've ever
heard of it's like number two
or seven on the top party schools of oh
hell we got chico up north okay so it's
comparable so i was going there in high
school
you know my sophomore year so you are
just like me yeah so you know the older
kids is not a good idea i suggest you
guys don't do it because when they
graduate
then you got no homies yeah it's true my
homies were three years older than me
hey but it was fun though you know
[ __ ] awesome you don't gotta drive
they make sure you're okay because
you're younger you black coach ladies
like anything it's just like
hey i was having fun oh i had fun too
yeah
so i didn't really need that college
experience to be honest in college i was
just like
working just going ham well man you got
it all out in high school to
be successful in college that's like i
said good method
yeah it's usually opposite yeah no i
know i know i'm thankful i'm very
thankful that it worked out the way it
did
and my parents were very like hey if
you're going to smoke you're going to do
[ __ ] do it here like at least you're not
oh no we were like dude all my friends
second lady
said you're allowed to smoke my mom my
mom actually was the
the the i mean she smokes weed to this
day like i mean
i mean that's she's more of a my dad was
not really into
like but he but he would much prefer us
doing it at the house so
you're saying such a taboo thing for
mexican ladies i've
you don't know do you have another
family what are they i can just see them
yeah but
yeah but see even my even my other my
mom's side of the family is still like
you're fine with weed yeah wow you are
rare
yeah you're a rare one you're very
[ __ ] lucky it's worse than
not speaking spanish bro it's worth not
speaking spanish but you smoke weed
drug addict i know my son lives here
he's on meth no he's my son
yeah i know it's probably nice broken
the
coke and beer that's like dinner that
exactly coconut no i did a line
where's my food i swear to god
that's just mexican family i grew up
with that [ __ ] dude yeah i know it's
crazy you know
so where'd you go after that after you
stopped doing top ramen food and [ __ ]
how'd you get
your next craigslist just looking for
work craigslist looking for work and uh
my my roommate at the time shout out to
royal honor he was uh he was the
engineer at the record
record company that ended up folding
then he was working at i don't know odd
jobs
and he was connected to to the a couple
people
in san diego that were at the
reservation the indians
oh [ __ ] and a couple of the young sons
of like the chiefs or whatever they were
um they were making so much money
because of their bloodline that they
their dad was like yo you got to do
something because you're making 50 80 or
whatever it was
a thousand dollars a month you got to go
figure out something that you want to do
so they became rappers
really yeah they became rappers and so
so one night
transition yeah one night he asked me
he's like you want to go san diego to
film this concert i'm like
sure and uh he's like you know you never
i don't even told me who it was for i
didn't know who they were at the time so
they were they were they weren't rappers
let's just say that you know they wanted
to be
they looked like rappers and they threw
money from the ceiling at san diego
house of blues
so i packed up my uh my little uh one
ship camera
grabbed my buddy rev and we drove down
there
and i'm walking in and i look up to the
thing and it's little wayne
little wayne's on the marquee i'm like
he must be here another night or
something because this was like carter
one had just uh carter two popping out
yeah carter two so carter two carter
three was
coming out was about to come out so i'm
like and i was a huge wayne fan at that
time you know like
that's college was just all wayne so i
was like nah he's was he here and then
sure enough they were open they paid to
open up for him
they got money oh yeah they got [ __ ]
money not only did they do that but
there was just bills their whole set
just falling from the ceiling
because they were they you know they
weren't the most entertaining you know i
had to do something for people to go yo
i love them
how to do something you know what i mean
but i'm right there in the in the pit or
whatever i don't even know what that is
underneath this was your first show
i've never been to a concert like before
that nothing like you know i'm playing
football i'm out here partying and stuff
i ain't going to concerts you know what
i'm saying
so i'm like and then they're like nope
everybody after the show's over you guys
have to go
you know you guys are out of here. and
i'm like no there's no way i'm out of
here and so my roommate ended up you
know he was
the mouthpiece of the group sure enough
they were like okay
you guys can shoot but you have to
deliver us a promo for
for wayne because he's going on tour in
europe so give us a promo with these you
know countries on it and whatever
and you guys can film so so we would
just give you a project you want
i mean i didn't even care about that at
that time i was just like i'm not moving
you know what i mean so i was just right
underneath and i'm just like i'm
freaking out you know
because i had never filmed anything like
really even that's someone you like
too someone you listen to i mean i knew
every right that the connection goes
back to i'm in college
just like we were talking about earlier
it's the connection of what you were
doing it brings you back
it was crazy it was crazy so that night
i was like yo i told my roommate royal
like yo we gotta get back let's get back
let's get back
drove back i remember what time we got
home two three popped in the tapes
started importing started editing you
know i edited um
like his live set of gossip and the song
gossip which was like
you know really hot at the time and i
put it out and this is 2008
on youtube so no one no one was really
popping on like it wasn't really doing
anything there was
videos of people running on trampolines
and [ __ ] yeah yeah you know what i'm
saying
so i put lil wayne gossip official music
video oh
and so every the next day acted every
every blog had it and mtv and everything
so it's
on your own channel yeah yeah but i mean
at this time though
it's like i mean it got a million or you
know which was i mean just
humongous you know what i mean like in a
couple days but like
it wasn't like that like people weren't
subscribing like no one was really on
there like that but people were watching
on blog
just like but barely you know yeah but
it's something you created and the first
big thing i was oh i was gas i mean
because
everything i'd done before this was like
hey here's a box of like 500 tapes for
27 dollars
can you just import those for me i'm
like all right i guess so yeah
exactly get some top ramen so uh so yeah
i just
you know i don't know there was nothing
there was no money or anything you know
no it's just that [ __ ] connected to
it but then i i ended up checking my
youtube like after i finished the little
promo form for for wayne's people
and uh dj ski was uh starting ski tv
which was
he was a games dj and he was like hey
i'm starting this thing i looked on his
channel he had about four videos
and i met up with them and i you know
they didn't have much money it was a
startup
and i'm like all right i just want you
know ownership and i just want to
partner up and oh of
ski tv yeah smart yeah right so
it was just us and and next thing you
know like i told him i said look i can
do this bro like i'm ready to go
you know what i'm saying and little
wayne invited me out to to the
uh lollipop music video i saw the way
like an actual music video set ran
60 [ __ ] people i was like yo this is
trash i'm like not in the trash like
that but like i
i did this in film school i'm i'm
prepared let's go oh you're saying like
ah this is what i'm made to do yeah like
you didn't put me in
i knew what it was yeah yeah i'm ready
to play i know the playbook so he
invited you over there you see it and go
is that the loose house i'm gonna kill
this what's the what the malus house the
owners of the sacramento kings at the
time oh [ __ ] and
they owned a cup the palms i think in
vegas
it was at their house yeah i was at
their house it was like you know i mean
that's where i met tyga and kendrick i
met kendrick was
his name was kdot at the time he was
like oh this is like pre-2010.
dude this is 2007 2008 maybe 2000
yeah i mean he was i mean passing out
his mixtape still
tyga had just got his his young money
chain um schoolboy q
all these guys so glasses malone was
still on the wreck on on the young man
damn i remember that yeah i remember him
so i met all those dudes there
you know we filmed the behind the scenes
came back oh you filmed
the behind the scenes of the music video
getting filmed yeah dude i brought it
first time i heard i was smoking blunt
across you from my house what a lollipop
song i smoked a blunt
oh yeah i was in the corner first time i
heard it the first time would you like
it or not
um i didn't listen to mainstream music
until i was 22. so [ __ ] that i don't
like that i was like oh it's on the
radio turn that off
i am not that was mad ignorant still
yeah yeah i mean it is what it is
no now that i think about it like if
you're on the radio you had good albums
to get
on the radio or you just had somebody to
now
now it's a little different you could
tell who bought it
even back then though i mean back then
there was only so many artists you know
what i mean it wasn't like i wasn't
interning
myspace i was on myspace still so my
myspace was still popping i had to reach
out to a homie to like
do some html weird stuff so my my thing
came out different than everybody else's
yeah so like that's how that's how back
in the day it was you know yeah
um so you see behind the scenes yeah
behind the scenes boom i brought all my
friends all my friends from film school
there was like seven
seven of us all of them had cameras some
two cameras dude
i had like 30 videos you know edited an
hour long bts i didn't know what i was
doing you know what i mean but uh
no one really cared about that and just
whatever but uh but ski you know so
and then i started hooking up with tyga
schoolboy q filming all the like videos
for them kendrick
j rock um that was you know question
yeah is j-rock ever signed to strange
music
i don't know i did i did some work with
strange too i went out to kansas city
yeah
um but i don't think so i was at a show
technically i just signed a new artist
he's from compton california
it's jay rock he's on his first first
tour but he's mad skinny
yeah i know he is skinny no like that
was mad skinny what year was this do you
know what year 2009
maybe 10. not because that 2009 he was
he was the
he was the the he was warner brothers
like main
um top priority there's another guy
named jay brock then has to because i
remember tech 9 brought him out i was
like yo this shit's hard
maybe but compton california i mean he's
from compton right now
does it say that he was assigned to
strange
what year was that strange music oh yeah
yeah right there
he then signed well so yeah this was him
because everybody came out and it was
like after 2007.
yeah okay so right now there's some gang
banger on a techno but this shit's hard
hard
i didn't know that yeah he came out he
was mad skinny he had a big-ass change
strange music chain
he's like we just signed this for this
tour wow this is the second show on the
tour
wow yeah i remember that today you guys
learned something i remember that shout
out to j-rock though you know top dog
all those
you know what i mean and like like i
said he was the he was on billboards he
had a song with wayne that was coming
out so like
it was it was crazy you know but no one
they weren't popping like like at all no
not yet not yet
and i remember the day that kendrick
changed his name from kdot we were
shooting a music video my buddy rev
was shooting a music video for him like
in our back alley and
and that's when he made his change we
actually have it on video like i have
the videos of it all that's the best
thing man you have a historical ass
moments yeah well i mean
i mean yeah you didn't know anything i
mean i have a bunch of other artists
that you know videos that didn't do
you know what i mean but it's like you
know it's just part of the journey you
know what i mean and it's so awesome to
see all these people
just you know become successful it's you
can only you know
be happy for oh absolutely it makes me
happy makes me excited it gets me gas
like
i'm i'm just really you know i don't
know it's just you know something that
you
how do you wish upon anybody anything
other than success you know what i mean
that comes
you if you do you won't last yeah i just
you won't last cause those vibes won't
fly yeah it makes me really happy you
know what i mean so so that was that was
really cool and then you know ski
um you know i met with ski and uh and i
didn't have a crew at the time though i
was just a direct director editor so i
was just like me and a camera
oh did you do by yourself all this yeah
pretty much getting that all the all the
people that i brought to the bts ended
up going back home working at
blockbuster
or you know motorola or whatever they
you know they just
lives sailed 120 in school bills and uh
had to get on with 20 bands
yeah oh yeah that's how much it cost to
go to film school oh your
face that's how expensive you have to
take a second mortgage
out that's why they did that yeah 120.
nah i mean for school
but some of these kids would take out
the max and i feel bad for what i got to
tell a story but one of my friends he
didn't understand that
the money he had to pay back
and his mom his parents ended up buying
a motorcycle
a motorhome with this money with school
money yeah
or with like you know uh federal and
so at the end we're we're sitting like a
day away from graduation and we're like
talking like about our loans and stuff
he's like oh i gotta pay it back or
whatever and we're like no you gotta
it's loaned to you you got to pay it
back and his face was
exactly like yours
[ __ ] reality check yeah so you're
120k
22 just at the jump oh man at least and
then
the job trying to live in l.a dude like
you know you owe another 120k
yeah it was you know so those a lot of
my friends went back and so i didn't
really have anybody else to rock with i
think like one percent of my school
actually like
went on to do anything like anything in
the industry
wow i realize that there's a lot of
people who like to watch films not
necessarily make them
so don't if you guys out there if you
like to watch films just go to the
movies or
yeah you know hobby pay for your net
netflix but do not go to film school
but um so then i was looking for a crew
and i met this rapper
and he was like hey i have this these
guys who have a bunch of lights and a
bunch of stuff
they're all living in a studio like six
of them in a studio they just graduated
at la film school
you want to get on the call i got on a
call with them and then ski called me
said hey can you meet me at the
at the studio and i went over there and
it was snoop studio we were shooting the
video for snoop snoop
dj and and uh terence martin
and uh uh that's what i meant ben ben
ben
ben balder ben baller the dude just
knocked out suge
um oh oh uh the gang banger dude yeah i
remember that yeah yeah
fema lopez he was a little kid at the
time he he was in the video
whoo the box he had the box
he's big right now but uh i didn't
realize until the other day i was
watching the footage i'm like yo that's
him
that's badass dude he was 11 or 10. what
a badass
to see a little prodigy grow up like hey
i got you on film dude
but i didn't even connect the dots but
uh but yeah so i called those guys i
said hey can you guys meet me over here
uh i'm at snoops and so they they they
came on the way
on the way yeah we had like eight
different kinds of cameras like
spare lights just whatever you know we
waited around for like 15 hours
[Laughter]
did she really you ready we got to
introduce the uh to the business
no that goes damn as long has you ever
waited
uh three days two days three days at a
set
nah i mean we went home we didn't sleep
there you know okay
say [ __ ] that [ __ ] so it goes even
sometimes with their own videos they
don't show up
really well the only time i knew that
was real is that young doug video where
they made it without his ass
i love that dude i love that [ __ ]
there's and there's a story like that
for every single
music video like that people do like not
just me everybody that's why i never
judge a music video i can't
because i don't know if the the artist
showed up didn't show up he wanted to
change the idea that day
they gave him ten dollars to shoot the
video they gave him a hundred thousand
dollars i don't know anything
so i can't i can't you know all the pain
that goes through that [ __ ] oh yeah i
know everything like it could be in
free video for all i know so damn so i'm
like i can't i can't i don't judge
videos anymore like that video so it's
good way to put it
nah hell it's a good way to put you'll
know what went into that [ __ ] dude you
never know man
i like that i like that outlook on it
you can't just judge [ __ ]
because it
it's not as good as your [ __ ] yeah yeah
or
or you know or they're garbage yeah i
mean no other garbage yeah sometimes
they're garbage but like sometimes
but just in general i just look at it
from a very
neutral standpoint just probably like
they went through hell like because if
all my videos there was a huge story
just similar to that one though really
oh absolutely can you tell me one yeah i
mean uh okay like common gnaws they
called me like the day before
date the day of for common and nas yeah
okay you want to shoot this we had no
treatment no nothing and
budget was a few thousand dollars so i
just grabbed the camera they're like hey
they're gonna be at the recording studio
do you want to just come there and shoot
a music video i'm like okay
and so you know like stuff like that
where i just grab a 5d and just go like
but the video did so it was such a big
song
and it did so well that you just
wouldn't think anything like that you
know
um people not show people not showing up
to your videos well that like yeah oh
yeah all the time i mean
and really late into their i mean it's
their own videos you know what i mean oh
yeah then the way you said it was that
and the biggest thing is like when they
go they show up they do one they do one
shot and they're like
so like what time you think i'll be out
of here
really all the time dude it's your own
craft like why would you not want to be
here make sure it's dope
i don't know i don't i don't know if
they are really sometimes maybe their
new artist they have the perspective of
like they don't understand what the day
is going to entail because my dad never
knew my dad would be very like
you guys are shooting that again you
guys what is that big old lens you know
and so i i kind of got a perspective
from him on maybe how somebody who
hadn't been through these trenches
before but a lot of times i'm working
with established artists so yeah
they know the [ __ ] going on yeah but
they are they're trying to get out of
there
i guess they're probably not trying to
have an 18 to 20 hour day which is
probably what they were
i'm with it that sounds bomb yeah but
yeah i kid i guess when you're
hold on i've never been rich as [ __ ]
either so i guess when you're rich is
[ __ ] you got like
fame you're like yo i got [ __ ] to do
yeah besides
the stuff i get paid to do but now but
see now that i know the way that
the industry works a lot of these i mean
they're they're not necessarily
rich i mean they're more well-off than a
lot but they're not necessarily like
and some of them aren't actually some of
them you know oh oh the record label of
money so it's just get the [ __ ] out of
here well yeah the way that it works is
like yo here's an
advance you know here's x amount of
dollars okay
you can spend that you always you pay
back but it's just for you to kind of
like live on and then we're going to pay
for your album
oh you want a haircut cool boom you want
this you want that and then once that's
all done
all right now you got to make us back
whatever it is that we spent usually
they'll have a number of one million
okay
you gotta make us back one million we
need to wreck yourself yeah and before
you see a penny
and if you don't make this back then you
guys make another album and we're gonna
spend another million dollars on that so
now you're in one five
are you pleased that's obviously a very
simplistic way to look at it but yes so
it's a never ending cycle of oh you
you owe me money if i make you look cool
if you well if you fly like if you don't
uh live up to standards you know and
then if you spend more money if you're
late to sets if you're getting arrested
if you're doing these
certain things i mean you know there's a
couple rappers out there who were really
hot they just couldn't
you know i'm not going to say their
names but they just couldn't they
couldn't
um they weren't with it and they started
losing a lot of money and they just
and their records were making money but
it just got to a point where the record
label was like you know you're this is
the liability it just doesn't make any
sense for us
i get what the record level is coming
from i get it the record label is a bank
they're basically saying here yeah also
not trying to give you no money extra
that you deserve it sounds like they're
just like no no we keep the 90
profit yeah you go make your own money
on tours on merchandise
on all that stuff because they'll take a
little bit from it not much and i've
heard the 360 deal is where they get a
piece of every [ __ ] thing you do
right yeah
so like i was i was with nipsey in
europe like for like three weeks
and uh i didn't even know who he was at
the time to be honest like i had i
ski called me he's like yo you're going
to europe nipsey hustle i'm like i heard
the name but i didn't know his music
he's like listen to the stuff
on the way there i listened to the whole
you know marathon marathon continues and
i was like
what the [ __ ] this guy's amazing then he
was he was talking to
rick ross on the phone with me and he
was like he had it on speaker cause we
stayed in the same room
and he was trying to sign him to a deal
whatever whatever and he told me after
that he's like look
he's like don't ever sign a 360 mat i'm
like i'm not a rapper
but he's like any time that comes across
you know your
your table or anything because they're
going to take a piece of everything that
you've already established
not even like from here on you know yeah
and so it's not for an artist taking
advantage yeah but at the same time
you're getting
a platform too it is yeah it is a given
give and take you know what i mean and
it just depends on how much you uh how
much you trust like how much you're
going to bet on yourself i mean i guess
how much you're going to bet on yourself
either way but
yeah i see i never had it fully
explained but that [ __ ] sounds like a
never ending cycle
it is and then so when i met tyga tyga
had just signed with the cadence which
was pete weintz from the fallout boys
label he was signed to gym class heroes
then he was signed a young money
young money was signed to cash money
cash money was signed to warner
so all those things had to get money
before he even got a penny
his manager whoever else god middlemen
times 10.
but then when you start signing with
people and they chain you up and stuff i
mean you know
kendrick had the same sort of similar
thing yet he had he had geffen
interscope aftermath
uh yeah and so eventually they cleared
all his stuff up but like wow
you see there's a lot more that goes
into that so much more than people think
just making music like you're a rapper
do it like full i'm [ __ ] tired
it's not yet and that's why that's why i
went into managing like i'm managing now
oh do you yeah i mean i'm brand new you
know i'm very fresh but you know
the industry i know the industry i know
how to because like a big part of the
industry is making the content creating
the content getting you know
um having ideas to even go hire somebody
to do these things you know so
that part is taken care of you know i
mean whether i'm doing it or i have
somebody else do it i'm creating the
ideas and everything like that
so um but as far as knowing the interest
now there's a lot of things i don't know
as far as
little details are like what's the
protocol here because i know you know so
that's
that's
interesting to learn it's it's it's out
of my comfort zone but yeah i mean
having this sort of experience having
this knowledge having all these people
that um
you know i've done work for and and if
the budget wasn't always up to
up to par i'd always be like hey you owe
me a song at my wedding and it doesn't
it doesn't look like i'm getting married
so i can kind of cash these in another
in other ways
no i get what you're saying so so i was
like i got you a problem i'm like yeah
i wanna i wanna you know i wanna i wanna
do more than just you know just just
shoot a video you know get into
everything and then you can always
remember
no i'll kill the video i'm just a
manager too
yeah i got that part you know what i
mean but but i also like i've seen so
much
of uh artists and you know just you know
ups and downs of things where
if i can help to you know get you out of
those landmines then
you know people they need that though
and that's that's what i'm here for you
know i mean that that that
that for me gives me more gratification
than shooting a video with a red camera
or something you know what i mean like
that yeah it's long i mean it's not
longer lasting because obviously the
video is forever music's forever
but it's more genuine and beneficial for
the person that's making the [ __ ] that
everyone listens to
absolutely you know i mean yeah you get
to a point where in
where i don't know i'm just about other
people you know what i mean like i just
i want to help out you know what it
means to be man yeah that's the that's
the best vibe you can give out is trying
to make it better so when you're gone
everybody goes no no
solid yeah absolutely solid as they come
yeah exactly and solid as a rock i'm
telling you dude like
that's a great way to look at it it's
really hard to find i mean now
since it's all monetized it's a little
bit easier like to find it hi
how you doing you know want to know how
to podcast we'll show you here like it's
you know now it's structured yeah but
it's monetized so like you don't really
know the genuine
where they're coming from you know what
i mean but but when i was coming up
there was nobody
to learn from so if i had questions i
had questions i just sat in my head
yeah dude what about you i mean did you
have a mentor or anything
no i was just selling packs got a phone
i said i sold past my life burner that
yeah yeah i got a smartphone and the day
i got smartphone
my girl was like get instagram i'm cool
apps [ __ ] that
[ __ ] i'm trying to be tracy yeah exactly
that was a thing i had instagram and
took a picture of a lemonade
and i was like yeah shit's sick i posted
it my friend came over to buy weed he
goes you know they
post weed on instagram go [ __ ] you no
and then i looked on and there's a whole
community online and i never knew there
was a weak community
did you get on instagram 2012. oh man i
had no idea
and then i saw like what's high times
cannabis cut what the [ __ ] they got a
cup's not a magazine
and then i was like you know what am i
going to do different so i would make my
thing was
i would make i would get toys like uh
you ever see reservoir dogs
i don't remember reservoirs okay there's
a scene where one of these
robbers cuts a cop tied to a chair and
he cuts slices his ear off oh yeah yeah
so i got like a nug i wouldn't bought a
fake wooden chair oh you stem legs
and i was taking like before videos i
was taking one two three four
doing a storyboard like not stop image
like
one didn't have videos i would post one
two three four
in one picture collage picture oh yeah
yeah so it'd be like a story leading and
like having him move then he sliced and
i put ketchup on the side of it like
he's bleeding
and i would just make movies like a
ramble first blood like him catch up on
your nugs
i mean i had your hounds i was like i'll
just waste a little bit of this now
yeah yeah and then it would look like
movie scenes and that's how i started
yeah i didn't show my face i didn't show
and you know i mean no one was doing
that right i was doing that [ __ ] i can't
imagine like that's that's
that's amazing that's like uh that was
fun though i i just i always reference
it to
forrest gump when he the lady drops the
book and he picks up the notebook hey
you dropped it he's not really there
yeah yeah yeah
but they did a good job of making it
look like he was there so that's my
whole motivation was
[ __ ] up things that you wouldn't think
that were real like i put myself on
stage with like the beatles and [ __ ]
well smoking a joke
just crop it in make it look it was
shitty on an
app but the concepts were yeah yeah
absolutely that's how i started yeah i
started i started filming off my phone i
just got a camera two years ago i was
just filming
22. you were 22 and turning 23 when i
started oh man yeah
that's fun it was [ __ ] great i
stopped selling weed though because my
face was on the
internet and my page got big so i
started going broke because i sell way
no more
damn bad that's tough what so i just got
another job that's when i got a job
again [ __ ] it
went just i was going to college still
hi uh welcome to taco bell can i take
your order please that was pizza
uh a pizza spot and i was selling weed
on the deliveries oh so then you had a
cover for it yeah and then i got
instagram so i
had to race out pizza spot i stopped
selling wheat and it got bad because
now i don't got a job so i went to
u-haul i said [ __ ] it i'm going to work
at u-haul i do moving companies
get discounts on these [ __ ] dummies
for my family and [ __ ]
so [ __ ] it and how long do you run that
for i did that for like a year and a
half and then
i started push trees as in my clothing
company and from then
from 2013 to 19 that's the
like the only money i made because i
don't get paid for content i'll get paid
for it youtube doesn't pay me
at all because it's uh because we
related i guess so what do you mean i
mean they're kept
i don't know i don't i don't know vice
got to that check mark and they show
crystal meth
so i don't know but yeah i know we we
could see marty knows we can see how
much money i make i don't get it it's
just uh transparent
you can't click on it i mean something
within the guidelines or something i
don't know they told me
straight up like [ __ ] you but in a
polite way but it's okay i just wanted
the platform to talk and
to make my videos running it up yeah so
um
i didn't do i just made pictures and
weird stupid [ __ ] until 2019 then i got
somebody to help me
and i stopped playing like anything
extracurricular no video
games no i just started to learn how to
edit there we go but like chocolate it's
like a video game right it's
i exactly like a video game except it's
beneficial for me
you know yeah people are like playing
video games i tell everybody why do you
work so hard like
for [ __ ] the reason you're watching
it that [ __ ] took 22
[ __ ] hours to film and edit right
it's eight minutes long
hey that's good have a good ratio that's
a really good reason yeah
yep my [ __ ] will be like 48 72 for like
a 30 second
thing damn i'm just filming the
apartment though in my back room
uh until we got this spot a couple
months ago beautiful beautiful thank you
congratulations
thank you thank you i mean it all pays
off yeah it does it does and i met marty
and then mario's no i know how to edit
and then he made our videos tv shows and
that's
the rest is it that's it i do base uh
skeleton i do a skeleton edit like i
want this this this this
it's 30 minutes long i give marty time
stamps like here to here can you make it
look like this here to here can you make
it look like this yeah
he runs it and we're done amazing works
great dude
got to get one of these marty's gonna
find find your twin brother
needs [ __ ] for himself i know we all
do oh if we did
[ __ ] we've been having [ __ ] three
videos out a week man but it's okay in
due time
um the reason i want to bring something
up you and marty have this wild ass
off chance connection for the dj ski
that's why marty's out here too yeah i
don't know if you guys talked about it
yeah a little bit yeah
yeah yeah so you started out and that's
how you got the ski tv yeah yeah so i
was running ski tv i was the head of
production i mean i was you know
business partners with dj ski dj ski was
i mean he's a mastermind in marketing
that's what the company actually was was
a marketing company although at the time
i didn't understand that so what we
would
what he would do and what we would do we
would shoot these videos for like new
boys you're a jerk um
basically new hot artist far east
movement flag of g6 these videos that's
your first big one
um no i think well dope boys travis
barker in game i shot like right away
but as far as like the one that went
number one it might have been soldier
boy turn my swag on damn you've been in
this for a minute yes either that one or
no
jerk jerk remember when that came out i
don't know what i was doing that yeah
it's all around the same flat like a g6
all around the same time um
but then we would take those views and
then we would go you know we would take
our analytics and go go show it to dodge
and stuff but these people didn't know
what the [ __ ] was going on because
this was you know 20 years ago like 10
15 years ago whatever
they just didn't understand we're like
look we get this many people whatever
and uh and so then we they would let us
do little little
campaigns and stuff and so that's what
we did you guys used the [ __ ] out of
that well
yeah you use that [ __ ] to [ __ ] segue
into some [ __ ] i mean these are
analytics
yeah no we shot that video yeah
but we premiered it on our channel so
back could we created vivo people was
created because of us
really because we we were premiering the
videos we were like lyrical lemonade
before lyrical lemonade
whoa if you move the foundation right
there we still have the videos up i mean
on ski tv like um i mean maybe
interscope may take a couple of them
down but like we were premiering them so
then we could take our actual analytics
from our channel
we were getting the subscribers and this
is before i mean this is this is
this is pretty huge yeah absolutely
doing it right now that's insane yeah
we were one of the we were the first
chair and we were we were the first like
um
like mtv but for youtube i mean i don't
know what that is now like
you know if you're performing all those
huge
lyrical lemonade yeah literally but
we're also doing like documentary we're
doing a bunch of content you know what i
mean we were
like it wasn't just music videos we were
doing stuff for the nba we were doing
you know this is
interesting this is yeah and uh and
he just had that that mastermind you
know but um and we ended up doing we
ended up teaming up with karma loop i
think in 2015
11 yeah right and we did the first music
first clickable music video with icecube
and his two sons but you could we did
three of them you could watch the video
and then you could click on anything and
just it would go right they were wearing
yeah go right into your shopping cart
but people it was just too too ahead of
its time whoa i would do that [ __ ] now
this is too heavy that's amazing that
was two ahead of its time i mean this
was
almost eight nine years old you made a
music video and on the overlay graphic
of it they can have clickable links like
say everything
anything classes absolutely go to your
cart yep yo where's that at
where's that no where's that at right
now like for every [ __ ] thing in the
world
i don't know i'm with it yeah karma luke
whoa
no [ __ ] yeah i used to buy everything
off karma luke yeah right yeah
uh what was it uh come on dr james
remember dr jays
it was like i was i wasn't i was
horrible horribly fast like i had no
style
i i had no style i used to wear that
[ __ ] in high school oh my god
damn yeah he's brought back some [ __ ]
memories yeah right like so it was it
you know that's that's kind of where our
my foundation as far as professionally
lived on and then icm saw fly like a g6
they the
one of the agents um he just really
liked that video and it reminded him of
um
smack my [ __ ] up by prodigy and that
was a badass video so it was similar to
that had that vibe and then once i
explained to him like the budget the
time restraints kind of what we were
under and the way that i was able to
shoot it and do things i mean
at that time interscope didn't even want
to show far east movement like they
didn't want to show the band
because you know they were like kind of
like the first pop asian group and it
wasn't really
they weren't sure if that was going to
hit hinder or like you know deter
or maybe make their growth bigger they
just they want to risk it the first
record
because i understand i guess so no i was
like [ __ ] that
so so we ended up shooting the video and
i ended up shooting like the stuff with
them first person pov stuff so you did
the exact opposite oh you want to show
them here's a [ __ ] first person pov
yeah kind of but i just intercut it with
this really hot chick so then it was
cool
you know it was herpeo beat the whole
video so so um
so then he's you know he's like hey uh
you know i'll start you know throwing
you some scripts you're gonna be
represented by us as a feature film
director is like cool i didn't even know
what icm was i called my dad my dad was
like hey matt
uh you know i'm still your dad and you
can call me for emotional things or
whatever but all this stuff is over my
head as far as i don't really know what
any of this stuff is and contracts and
stuff like
get yourself a lawyer and yeah and i
didn't no you didn't did you get [ __ ]
you know i'm still walking the limp
nah bad yeah i mean it's just part of
the game you know what i mean like i
wasn't even because
you know when you're creative you're not
really yeah into that you're like oh no
no you want me for the things in my
brain cool don't [ __ ] me over because
i'm gonna do good [ __ ] yeah
and it's like you know you're my brother
you're my your business partner that
sucks man i've been through three of
those
so what do you do totally you move on
with stride and stress
for a little while like i stuck in that
and i was stuck and then that kind of
you know it was a big chapter of my life
you know to be a big chapter of my
journey because
i'm sure a lot of people go there you
know or have been there and it's like
what do you do you can't blame the world
because
i could have got a lawyer you know what
i mean like i it was on me
you know it wasn't on them like their
businessmen they're gonna
make the best deal for themselves that's
what business is then you negotiate
what's the best for you
and so i'd learn that you know what i
mean and uh and then now i'm good
good man but damn i know damn so you got
like one of your biggest things to start
it got you a huge opportunity then they
go nah
[ __ ] you yeah yeah yeah yeah
oh yeah but it's i mean it's okay like i
said that's what i wouldn't be here
though
yeah you're here for a reason now
absolutely so
yeah when you fly like g6 right
yeah when you have the concept what are
you doing are you writing out the ex
a whole the whole video step by step
storyboard
i did that so my first music video with
game i you know fresh out of film school
maybe six months whatever you know we
learned how to write storyboards scripts
i mean we
blocked the actors all the rehearsals
everything right so i
am i showed up to to a games video
because obviously it was the game
featuring travis barker i'm like whole
you know damn but at the same time i'm
ready to go you know we got two reds
and we were the first i was the first
one to ever shoot a music video on the
red i think i was
ever that people so people didn't know
how to use the reds and all my buddies
lived in that one apartment or one
studio
worked at a rental house and the rental
house had just bought 30 of them
they were the only company they were the
only place in l.a you could get them but
they didn't know how to use them
so they're like here you young guys
figure this [ __ ] out yeah
so we had two reds that day red ones
okay
and uh i had a clipboard and a big old
thing and
my dad was there my mom was there and
games like hey uh so what do you want me
to do he didn't like me
at all but at first i mean i'm you know
five five one
[ __ ] dude with anything i think i got
the clipboard and i got the clipboard
right and then he goes well probably
this is probably what he didn't like
he's like what do you want me to do i'm
like okay did you not get the uh did you
not get the
shot list did uh i'm like okay let's go
here let's go to page 392.
did it like that and i'm like okay so it
says game enters from the left
of the screen camera and he's like bro
where do you want me to stand
yeah simplify that [ __ ] for me tell me
what to do after that i realized that
okay i was like
simplify this [ __ ] for everyone so
that's when i stopped writing every
single period oh really
yeah and do you're not winging [ __ ]
though you you have to have
enough room in there too because you're
going to have guys who come late you
have guys who come early game guys who
say hey i got to be out of here at this
time or you can have the whole video get
shut down cause someone has a gun or
um for real oh yeah a celebration the
game with uh
the game the video with uh little wayne
chris brown everything we had to park
a couple pieces she got wrapped real
quick because people got a gun that's it
yeah you know the gun not when you're
all in a like you know in
at a barbecue like it was it was a video
shoot you know i mean
there was a video shoot and we had cops
obviously there because we blocked it
all off it was a huge it was a huge
video it was like 200 grand so it was
like
it was like trailers and everything and
then you got these dudes that
you know just out there just wilding so
got you alcohol
it's um get shut down real quick so
you're done
can you come back tomorrow yeah oh so
did you stop for the day
yeah yeah just i mean you know like you
got to get everybody out there make sure
like
things don't escalate and uh so they're
basically just trying to make sure
nothing goes
pops off while come back later kick
these guys out yeah you still got to pay
for the permits you got to pay for the
cops got to pay for it
you have your trailers there you have
all your crew guys which you're paying
you know x amount of money for
their day rates i mean your food's
already made
makeup's already on yeah so you know
what a loss
i mean for us i know i'm just in channel
it's probably
that day was probably about 50 60 grand
day oh
yeah so sick man you're over here your
dad's filming you don't like it you're
doing huge music videos
what a difference yeah good [ __ ] you
know you had to at least stand and go
[ __ ] yeah at least once at least that
first time yeah a couple times i mean
when i was like
so the thing was i was really um like
progressive with social media so
um you know we met with twitter when
twitter came out and and we just
i remember i remember flying to vegas
with ski and ski would tell me to bring
an extra pair of clothes and i was like
for what
and and he'd be like let's take a
picture and so we would post it when we
weren't working
and that was like the bow wow challenge
before the bow wow challenge so that we
always looked busy at our company yeah
you know what i mean even though we were
laying in our beds or whatever and i
didn't unders you know understand but
then i got it perfect
oh it's genius genius you know what i
mean so so i was just really big on on
just pushing myself so that so that's
when i
you know it just it was just all kind of
came together you know what i mean i
learned
i learned a little bit of that learned
the filmmaking stuff and and i just you
know
yeah looked around like well you did
this [ __ ] all by yourself
i mean not no i'm saying you have help i
get it i'm talking about
the drive and the motivation to get
[ __ ] played and get up and keep doing
it again oh that's what i'm going to do
it again absolutely i mean that's
perseverance that's just um resilience i
mean that's something that is that was
something that was instilled in me at a
very young age my dad used to point to
that see that guy right there
yeah he was a all-star running back and
one knucklehead decision now he's you
know sitting in front of mcdonald's do
you want to be like that
and i was like i did it's my brother it
works
it works and i saw how hard my dad
worked i had a lot of fun in high school
i had you know they were always loving
supportive i know i had a really good
childhood so
um you know i had every had every reason
to
to succeed you know what i mean like so
what was i going to do you know
but are you an only child no i have one
little sister oh okay
for some reason sound like you're the
only child no no my sister my sister was
popping she was a
skater like a pro skater she oh [ __ ] and
she was like she's little
really little she was going on the the
half pipes and yes that's why she got
you know
what she's crushing right now now she
doesn't skate no more i mean she's how
does she
uh 32 oh so this is a while ago yeah
yeah and this is when we were in high
school like when i was in you know
coming up you know i mean she was a
skater she was badass but she was
i mean she was so little you know she
looked like a little like a little boy
because she cut her hair real short she
was like a tomboy
so she was popping sick yeah and i made
a little skate videos and stuff
well i mean dude that'd be a badass
skate video right i mean dude she was i
mean she's little to this day she still
had i mean she's really little she looks
like a 16 year old
so it's super it was really cool for
skateboarding yeah that's what i'm
saying oh yeah she's flying and then
all the little girls are little kids
looking up to her like just lazy yeah
yeah i just couldn't relate to her even
though like she was
you know not their age but they thought
so it was it was really good for brands
you know it was cool man yeah super cool
very cool your [ __ ] parents had cool
kids yeah i mean
they were great parents you know what i
mean and so i think when you when you
put that attention towards your kids
which i think parents
should do and need to do if they're
going to have kids you know what i mean
then
you know you guys are going to turn out
all right yeah man yeah of course
i [ __ ] love it dude um
i know i won't get too off topic but now
let's go i mean not even off topic so
you do the flight of g6 the celebration
one i i was going through a bunch of
[ __ ] going through all your stuff
so how the [ __ ] do you acquire
such crazy clientele just from that one
video word of mouth and people just
loving it
or yeah also how does that work i mean
ski was really connected right and so
then we were oh
and we were also a marketing company so
we were taking this and just kind of
pitching them that way and what we did
and i think ski once again because he's
a mastermind you know so ski was really
good at hearing a bunch of records and
being like
okay you know matt which one do you like
okay we're gonna shoot these ones i was
like okay cool we're gonna shoot those
ones but everyone that we
in songs i didn't like he was like we're
gonna shoot this song
and they were all hits he knows though
so that that was i mean so we would take
you know that as preference over budgets
or anything like that because we didn't
really care about the
small amount of money we wanted the look
we wanted the views because at that time
like i said this wasn't
that's about foundation building block
absolutely and then we could go take
this and
you know we sold the karmaloop for a lot
of money millions of dollars we sold
a small amount of our company too so
there was a lot of a lot of things
bigger than just like the view or the
the budget the five ten
twenty thirty forty fifty thousand
dollars and um and so that really
propelled you know me and us as a
company and then stamped you yeah once i
left there
um i got repped by one of the biggest
reps in you know in the music video
industry
and uh shout out to taj taj brought me
on um he was over
at a riveting and um he left riveting
and
and
i was with happy place tara razavi and
jamie conrado which were like producer
and uh and
music video rep extraordinaires and so
what do you mean music video rep what is
that
it's like your representatives kind of
of of people that make videos
yeah yeah it's like your agent at icm
but of music video directors yeah i mean
that's what they yeah that's what they
have out there yeah oh
[ __ ] i didn't know that i didn't know it
was like that oh yeah really yeah yeah
so that's how you basically go hey uh
justin bieber we have matt alonzo here
and he's done this this this this here's
his work here goes yeah take him
kyle yeah let's hire kind of but it's
more like i'm friends with
my commissioner my my music video rep is
friends with you and your
scooter or you're you know the head of
interscope
or you're the commissioner and so you
know so
and if they like your work obviously i
mean you have to you can't stress
something
yeah you can't be trash you know they
mean it um but it was pretty much like
that and then also like
the they send solicitations out every
record company has a a person called the
video commissioner their job is just to
make sure that a video gets from a to z
done that's their job they have to like
oversee it all make sure that they can
pick the director
they pick the idea you know they do
everything so
um that person sends that out to like 50
people you know
all day like hey you want to write this
right in this and so my agent would go
through those and then
select them for me and then i would
select them even more so and then so we
would just kind of oh i see
it was a whole bu dude that's a lot of
work that goes into a music video dude
behind the scenes holy [ __ ] but you know
the the one part that's even kind of
crazier is that you have to write an
entire treatment you have to write like
the idea the script
all the pictures everything which takes
a couple days i mean
and then that's before you even get the
job that's just for you to throw it into
the mix and there's another 5 10
15 50 100 of those is that why you're
saying some people have this treatment
it doesn't matter if it's miley cyrus or
this or this is
that's what they're doing it's because
they put so much time into that
treatment it doesn't matter because
that's not gonna get picked
gotcha like it's not gonna it's just
because they're stubborn and they don't
understand the difference of brands yet
like they don't
you know because there was a time i
looked at it from like what i wanted to
do and stuff like that
but you know ski brought me back along
or my rep and
my other producer were like okay get
with it you know what i mean so
but i was always pretty good with that
but a lot of kids they just don't
understand
what they're actually doing they just
see the camera the ak
and they want to be cool they want a
picture and then they're holding the
camera yeah and they want something that
they want in their mind
just for them not necessarily for so i
tell them just make your passion project
don't don't do it for a client that's
what i enjoyed about film school is that
i
i got to get all my stuff out of my
system without having to like be liable
for it
yeah no i said although i did pay like a
buck 20 for it so
[ __ ] is the knowledge [ __ ] but if
you're saying it helped you a hundred
percent
for me [ __ ] was worth it man for me and
and one thing i i
i always one thing i'll say if you want
to go to film school if you want to go
to film school
and you have like a passion to go to
film school go to film school because
you're the one person
who's gonna actually do something with
that you're the one percent yeah
and um if you if you're questioning
don't go to film school
if you have any doubts because you might
get through it but you just it's a waste
of money for yourself
you know while you're working in a
[ __ ] office going now i can film your
whole video because before
before they told us to go to college
like our parents would tell us to go to
college
only only the people who went to call
the people who went to college were only
the ones who wanted to go
back in like the 60s and whatever so
they were the ones who wanted to go
that's why they were able to be
successful and then people were like oh
if you want to
hey kids if you want to go to call if
you want to be successful you have to go
to college but it's like no
if you know if you're if you're going to
be successful perfect sense i know but
it's it's just
it's unfortunate because it's it's
pushed on to you oh you're not going to
college
[ __ ] people that's the only reason i
went i didn't want to [ __ ] go
you do five years did you play any ball
not in college so you got two years left
you have four years of eligibility
to play football bro so this is this guy
named mack right
i know this guy named mac he played uh
division one
okay i was a lineman like um even though
i'm not tall i will
[ __ ] your day up i don't give a [ __ ] how
strong you were it's
levitt it's leverage lights out for real
so he was telling me this is three years
ago he's like no i
i still chill with the michigan state
and we do drills because he's [ __ ]
six
six monster offensive lineman monster
but i see fools like that like well i
get lower than you i win you ain't [ __ ]
i'm short
[ __ ] you i win yeah but you're running
back and [ __ ] like
that was good for you call heartbroken
get you back out there bro
so this is the thing he's like come with
me he's like how hold you
you got this you've got this many years
left you can still go back for this this
and this
oh wait you got all your agility so i
was having dreams for like four months
that i was playing football again
and i wake up just sad as [ __ ] like no
no
i [ __ ] i had it but then it got me
thinking
yo you're six [ __ ] six you're
benching 440. yeah
you're gonna pay for my broken legs nope
oh no i don't think i want to play
football yeah i would love to man
oh my god i would [ __ ] love it but i
can't i'll break something and
i just can't risk that dude yeah and i i
understand that they had alumni games
where i'm from
and uh they have they have them like
every five years and like every five
years i'm like oh yeah i'm gonna play
the next one wait they let you they let
people come back alumni games yeah i
know
what that is alumni meaning like anybody
who graduated can play so there's a
rival team
and we actually played at santa barbara
city college they played the game at
that place mad dangerous
dude you got you got 60 60 50 year old
running backs
no i don't know that's it full gear like
yeah i mean
full on bro you get your hell you get
your helmet from you know yeah
absolutely
okay i know you got that one dude from
napoleon the uncle from napoleon how
much you better
throw this football in that mountains
that's my favorite part
you know you got a whole squad of those
dudes [ __ ] a bunch of [ __ ] al bundys
you know but they're they ball out you
know what i mean it looks fun
but you know that sounds [ __ ] awesome
i think about it how the [ __ ] do we get
on that
you gotta go to the school oh go to
school sorry you might you probably
petition your high school for one you
know say what's up
oh man i have dreams like what up back
in school like
nah i'll [ __ ] you hey it's funny though
because like a lot of people switch
positions so all of a sudden
you're you know the the nose tackle is
getting the ball in the back yeah
like you know now he's a running back oh
no i i tried out for [ __ ]
and quarterback won the position they
weighed me and said you're a [ __ ]
lineman
two years in a row i beat out my friend
justin for running back position they
weighed me go this is all
before high school she had to be weighed
like a city oh yeah yeah yeah the little
guys right i
beat every [ __ ] person in every
single tryout on the first day and they
go you're [ __ ] fat though
oh man but why would they weigh you in
because don't you just need to wait
i have to make the team no no no uh city
league is you wait before every game
oh yeah yeah every single game but then
i was always heavy so
fifth grade i'm with his uh yeah yeah
okay it was not fun getting punk like
that [ __ ] suck
that [ __ ] sucks but it got tough as [ __ ]
like that that's good and that's good i
should do junior lifeguards
uh oh wow yeah cause i was like you know
in the ocean
yeah yeah like because i live right
there so but i did that just so i could
stay
oh in shape yeah because i'd eat junk
food all day i'm sweet tooth
school man no even like younger like
when i played youth football like you
know what you're talking about like
my dad my dad made me like you know you
want to play ball
you better be training like you're in
the nfl yeah my dad was not like that
i was i was on my [ __ ] oh with that
[ __ ] i was eating those uh
rollers from 7-eleven you know those
things on the [ __ ] hot dog trays the
rollers and chickens
i used to eat those and go but i gotta
weigh in
[ __ ] how many times i ran with a trash
bag over my body right
hey we all did it yeah i was that kid
man running up the hill every [ __ ]
game full pads
i [ __ ] hate it just give us give us
ten more pounds [ __ ] i know
i get it though little [ __ ] kids that
barely make the weight get crushed and
then they also had high school kids who
like maybe if you were a freshman and
you didn't
be in jb and you could pl but you didn't
want to play you could play for the
eighth grade team
so that's why they had to wait yeah
absolutely i had a couple kids on my
team you got a small town if you're
doing that
no like a lot of like i never heard that
my yeah that's why they would weigh you
like that you know what i mean
because it doesn't make much sense once
you get to the to the to the top tier of
the
little leagues right like after that
it's like you should be a free-for-all
but they have to do it because
the kids come down you probably you
probably played against or had it one
one kid had a full [ __ ] beard that's
what i'm saying like you know
they went to continuation school like
you know what i'm saying like
yeah could you imagine playing like a 19
year old kid
there was like a i think like a 16 year
old on my team he was a fullback he was
bad bro
he was bad fullback's the scariest
position he's [ __ ] are tough
he was bad he wouldn't even wear a shirt
or socks
he was white guy yeah but he like i
don't know i don't know where he was
from he was a street dude he was just
street he was smoking cigarettes dude
like bad news bears he'd be smoking
cigarettes when he like
i remember one game he got kicked out he
just sat there and smoked a cigarette on
the sideline
you know santa barbara is the [ __ ]
place to be do you hear this over here
like that
you know everybody's all you know soft
now so
[ __ ] smoking vapes dude it was crazy
no more six well he was just hitting
menthols that's at 15 or whatever he was
though i remember smoking newports for a
minute
bro on the sidelines with his pads on
that's [ __ ] preposterous bro
why isn't any coach just stop that
that's crazy but you know what
santa barbara it's a different time he
was a good kid he just you know didn't
have much family and just kind of didn't
have much direction so yeah i mean
keeping them on the field
even if you got kicked out just keeping
them there was keeping them out of
trouble
i don't even think about that got kicked
off the [ __ ] game oh yeah he was not
the best kid
oh yeah yeah yeah he just threw a punch
yeah you know
hey when you're not getting attention at
home you act out another last show
that's the one thing i wish you know
teachers would realize is just like yo
it's not a bad kid he just needs some
attention man just tell the kid good job
some sometimes something you know what i
mean we've seen of movies
that's always the case it's obviously
people don't understand that though you
know what i mean it's just unfortunate i
studied psychology a lot i was going to
do a documentary on
mental health within hollywood because
oh i mean
you have to be a little off to endure
what i endure and then to endure with
like
an artist or an actor or it's humble
it's a whole nother life
you don't have your life no more you
don't have your life and you go through
so many downs that like most people
would just be like nah i'm gonna work at
vons because like
i can just have a oh yeah there's been
some times where so much pressure
like i i just i miss having a job and
not having everybody depending on me
no i'm saying there's times where i
think that like how much easier was life
when you didn't have a million people
going where the [ __ ] the [ __ ] at
where's the new [ __ ] i'm saying like you
like that though i don't
but you do don't [ __ ] dm me that
[ __ ] but you do though because i
realized eventually like
i would you know it's for myself like i
don't want to let [ __ ] down
i know borders sad at home i know that's
what it is not the people like
where's our [ __ ] [ __ ] those people i'm
saying all
this sort of like you know um anxiety
all of it gets us hot like it's
going you know what i mean and like
working at bonds doesn't there's no
anxiety there
no no it's it's the it's the process of
because every [ __ ] four businesses
and sometimes i'm like i need an
assistant
because i have no time and i'm hitting
all these all this [ __ ] all at once
doing this doing that
there's like okay it's been a full day
[ __ ] i haven't eaten
exactly i mean today
you know what i mean i didn't eat today
so i had to think if i ate today
yeah see but what i'm saying is that
most people like my dad he was like what
are you doing like even to
this day sometimes he's kind of like
yeah she didn't want to get a regular
job because
it just doesn't register to him well i
could never do it
i either could i sit there and go you
know what i could be doing right now but
that's why that's why i realized like
okay there's a certain breed there's a
certain
and i think it's childhood sort of
trauma
child either the actual um
you know artist or actor or something
they've experienced something in their
in their childhood that
you know gives them this perseverance
and this sort of resilience to get
through these things to be able to
to achieve the time see that you know
what i mean because if you if it's not
like if it's not there
then you just you know there's no reason
to endure that
yeah i totally understand that you know
and so i started studying mental health
a lot and i really started looking into
all this stuff and uh
and i was going to put together a
documentary started interviewing
psychologists and
and i was going to run it so like all
the artists that i've worked with all
the actors and everybody do i sit down
absolutely because everybody i mean it's
good because people think
you're celebrity you're so [ __ ] rich
and you're all this like no you have no
idea what the [ __ ]
that's the part that that's the part
that really got got me eventually was
like
people think perfect i don't know what
they think that you know money
all that stuff money pressure fame all
that does is cause
more of course mental health issues but
people don't see
it that way and that's the the thing
that people get pissed off i used to get
pissed off a lot
like yo you're famous just stop
acting and be rich that was my thing
because i grew up poor as [ __ ]
so i'm like you got money you [ __ ] you
know i'll give me money i'll take all
the pressure
that's that's what's more of like you
know just quit what you're doing if it
[ __ ] your life up and just keep the
money
you made it yeah that that's how i used
to think yeah but it's like no it's not
as simple as that man it's not
because if you stop maybe 30 people
around you have no more income
and i don't i mean it's not even that
for sure you know what i mean but at the
same time
hopefully those are 30 people that are
working with you not just like hey no
i'm saying like if you're the brand
like no we do this we do this we do this
as you see this this i'm talking about
more of like
yeah i get that yeah i understand that
you know what i mean but at the same
time it's like uh
you know they have that's their identity
like you know that's our identity it's
really hard to
you know and i'm looking at like people
on even crazy level
yeah because at that point like they
don't i don't i don't think you can't
step away as a [ __ ]
i don't think and i don't think a lot of
them necessarily want to
to do it all the time you know what i
mean but um and
it makes sense if you think about the
times you're pressured and then think
about okay
time's up by a thousand oh yeah
absolutely no
i get all these people are freaking the
[ __ ] out every day all day go to school
you don't know who to go to the store
you don't know who to trust you know oh
yeah i don't know
your friend you don't know if that girl
likes you for you or for you know
you know nothing at that point so it's
kind of sad it is and so
and so i just wanted to show people and
to let people know that hey you
everybody's the same we so that they can
actually accept whatever it is they need
to accept because
their celebrity you know idol goes
through what they go through and they
can say oh okay cool
as opposed to trying to be but they
don't relating to people that you've
gone through the same [ __ ] is so much
better than you think it is until it
happens to you you go home
you did the same [ __ ] thing how'd you
get through it so did i
yeah and then you think okay if it's us
two there's a million
that's why i can't really tell it like
third party and so i was like okay i'm
you know i got an investor for this
documentary right right sounds great
don't covet hit and it was uh it still
still sounds like something that
nobody's done it'll help and it's
informational
absolutely i mean and i study i study i
mean it's it's
fascinating to me just uh personality
disorders traumas you know all these
things that we experience and it's
it's i don't know i mean it you can
pretty much you know
count up a certain amount of things and
kind of see how somebody's gonna make
their decisions
and so like a bucket like you've done
this there and you [ __ ] up things he's
probably leaning this
yeah yeah and so if you can identify
those things within yourself then you're
able to make
you know be conscious of these
subconscious choices that you normally
would leave you hear
think about that like that and so now
you can actually say oh i'm you know try
not to do these things yeah
yeah i checked myself on stupid [ __ ]
like why'd you do that
you don't need to do that like i i know
what you're saying you have to check
yourself
and be embarrassed of your own actions
when no one's around
well that's that's most important most
important like yo i drop trash now i
pick it up and no one's around okay you
have to you have to be here you know
what or what because if not i'm a piece
of [ __ ]
who who sleeps with you i mean like you
know you go to sleep with yourself you
know i mean like how are you gonna sleep
that night
going through the next building yeah so
i mean that's just one thing i i really
i really got into and i just really
wanted to like i just wanted to help
people
yeah yeah do you especially right now i
know you're saying this before covert
most important now you know how many
people just went [ __ ] nuts this year
well i mean
so every seven minutes a a man commits
suicide and this was before coven
this was before now absolutely
i mean you've been i mean and i think i
think about the kids who like eight only
eight at school like the kids who got
like the you know like the
yeah lunch line right um luckily i would
just like move
move move would shake and grab a little
bit of this little that but like
if you're not at school you're not
eating at all that's the first thing i
thought about
if i was in this what the [ __ ] would i
do at home
and if you had abusive parents or you
have anything like that you're with him
all day
dude it's it's that was my school was
the escape sometimes
most of the time getting out of the
house for a lot of people like my house
was like
a spot where my dad just was open arms
and anyone could spend the night
bought people cleats like whatever he
just you know food that's tight whatever
he did
what did your dad do he worked for the
city of santa barbara now city of
modesty he just retired this weekend so
yeah yeah yeah yeah you know he's
chilling now so he's uh he actually
wants to go and help young fathers you
know like
young men who are and i'm trying to
explain to him it's a whole other world
out here dead completely different
you know women married to and have kids
to get the money and he's like i don't
understand i'm like that's just the way
it is nowadays you have to just be in
the occupation at this point absolutely
there's youtube channels on it hi
welcome to
how to divorce your husband to get all
the money you know and it's it's not
something i like to say but it's reality
yeah
and so you have to be aware of it and uh
so hopefully he you know trying to send
him some videos and
that's awesome though but i think a
hundred percent that
project you want to do is something that
neat it's not even like you want to do
it patchy
it needs to be done because i'm a
hundred percent
it's like uh hi i'm kobe bryant you
should drink sprite
what about this like high meek mill and
sometimes i'm [ __ ] depressed too
[ __ ]
how do you deal with it exactly it's
true because uh another thing is
black males under like 40 or some [ __ ]
it's like the most taboo thing is mental
health
absolutely because they're like they
feel like a [ __ ] talking about
in our in the mexican community it's
like we talk about that [ __ ] oh no it's
like
devils it's like it's all what do you
mean you live here oh
you sad yeah it's it's not very like i
was talking to my mom and jesus like no
it's not even a thing and if you say
anything
it's not even real yeah it's it's like
you mean you're mexican you're immune to
and they do the
they do like the the catholic type stuff
and their prayers whatever whatever like
it's just like it works but it's not
even it's just like
didn't talk about it you know what i
mean so but it's like that everywhere
and like i said the higher you go the
more
either the more with it you are meaning
like you have no friends
you're very like in tune with yourself
uh or you're you know [ __ ] on tmz
going crazy
there he is but then again man but it
deserves a snap [ __ ] you've been
through a lot of [ __ ]
get me get it go for it yeah go for it
it's fine
and it i mean for me it doesn't i mean i
don't people who have their own journeys
i mean now if you're gonna do certain
things the kids are gonna you know act
you know show your character and more
than you know unrepeated
uh times like that's on you still like
you know what i mean but like
we all go through things you know the
cancer culture and everything else right
now it's just
i don't even know if i want to do a
mental health documentary got it i'm
just saying i'm gonna get cancer
no no one's gonna if they cancel you
they're gonna be at 500 million people
going hey that should help me
it's all good bill bird didn't get
cancelled so it can't cancel you if you
don't care
yo thank you billboard i don't give a
[ __ ] you think he even looked at the
headline oh
no yeah maybe just to write get some
more stuff together you have something
to write
i watched i [ __ ] love bill burr i
just watched the thing about the grammys
did you see it you see what he said
nothing nothing he doesn't know how to
speak their language like this is lame i
thought i was going to meet some people
here uh
all the feminists are mad by feminists
have you watched that have you watched
that i said
it have you watched it you could say
dick or [ __ ] you once oh [ __ ] i mean
dude the [ __ ] he said like
you should never hit a woman i mean yeah
we should let's dial that back don't be
so broad and it's completely true my mom
taught me how to make a girl not
hit me or hurt myself when i was four
he's like okay but to say that there's
no reason there's no reason so what if
you're walking and she's drowning both
your kids
can you pop her i mean come on he's like
i'll give you i'll give you a hundred of
them right now he's like he's like he's
like women
uh how many of you guys want to slap
your man right now and they're all like
yeah you know he's like come on you know
same with us that's what i'm saying
exactly but it's just like
he said so many i mean a period is is
more than what he said on that that
night yeah i couldn't understand that at
all i didn't get it i thought i was
going to see some [ __ ] i watched the
whole
highlight went dude he had a live set
like what was it two nights ago three
nights ago
i missed it like it was right behind my
house did uh he did he does an outside
show with
like theo vaughn i went to theo vons i
went to theo that
yeah jeremy pippen stopped by i did a
little surprise that was cool jeremy
piven
was on hotbox with mike tyson i [ __ ]
loved jeremy pittman and i saw him and
went
good match [ __ ] because jeremy's
funny [ __ ] and mike tyson doesn't talk
as much yeah so it's just getting really
[ __ ] up because
oh yeah mike tyson's my [ __ ]
shrooms last time or something last
night when i was watching
mike tyson bro that just re-did their
live work no no no
let's get high together amazing and the
stories that he tells man like about his
childhood
robbing and like [ __ ] up i mean [ __ ]
up when we talk about trauma mental
health
that's the example of it and it's like
and then he's getting people going no no
[ __ ] fight him kill him when he said
that he would fight just so that people
would
like him or love him that was like
that's when i was like man
you know it's just on a whole nother
level that i could never relate to on
that level
but it just shows you like there's kids
out there that are hurting that are
going to become adults you know what i
mean so knock your ass out
knock your hats out or ruin their lives
you know luckily he's able to bounce
back and i like that
such a cool turnaround the biggest
biggest turnaround in any celebrity i've
ever seen
amazing [ __ ] awesome awesome it's
awesome his podcast i mean he's fighting
holyfield they just announced it like
wait what yeah third fight
just announced it so look at here yo i
watched
the holy field of mike tyson uh hot
boxing i had no idea the backstory of
those two
i didn't know they knew each other like
that they bit his ear off no i knew that
i'm talking when they were kids
oh yeah they were in the tournament yeah
yeah i watched that one so you knew the
[ __ ] first and then you bit his
[ __ ] heart yeah
yeah you were a monster i was on 21st
street playing water balloons and i
heard everybody start screaming i ran in
and he's just bleeding
he was doing this and like stopping his
feet or some [ __ ] oh man
i'll never forget that i totally forgot
to listen to that the one that wasn't
a good one that was yeah that was good
that was good that was good um
that was real good so yeah we went man
off topic but we're all good it's all
good it's all good um i wanted to bring
something up
you said you got uh the rep and you know
dj has the connections
but yeah how the [ __ ] you doing justin
bieber [ __ ] like that when does it come
around to where you're doing
like chris brown just cuz those are
those those are music videos i get it
they're music
videos but those are also michael
jackson's status
[ __ ] yeah i mean i don't i don't maybe
because i didn't look at it necessarily
like that no no i don't mean it like
you know i get it oh [ __ ] no no i gave
her yeah that's not what i cause i was
just like yo what up yeah what's up dude
just to be really
nice i mean the more you the more normal
you are the like the better now
i would i wouldn't say like why are you
are you not fanning out no [ __ ] that
[ __ ] i mean
dude i did one time it was a boxer but
we'll get to that well
we don't have to get to that but um it
was just the natural progression i mean
you can only go
exactly i'm saying so after you're
getting this one you're doing this
you're doing this and now they're like
okay here's another level yeah you're
you're you're stamped you can come in so
like when i went to the
my rep and this other producer they they
set a cat for me because before that
would ski we weren't really worried
about the budget so we were more worried
about just making sure that the song was
going to be
you know big and and um you work with a
different brain to a music brain too
dude what the thing was like i had
nobody to help me at all
like i was just a little lost pup i went
to film school i'm
in a marketing company doing music
videos i had nobody there to mentor me
to tell me anything i didn't know how to
write a treatment i know how to write
budgets
as far as for music videos i knew
nothing you know what i mean and that
was kind of hard
so um and so
i totally forgot where i was going with
no you're saying in the natural
progression of going
yes oh so they set a cat for me then
once i graduate once i got out of there
they said hey look
you're not gonna take another video
until it's fifty thousand dollars and i
was like
yeah no i was i was flipping out because
i'm like fifty thousand dollars like i
like
wait like i'm gonna do what you get paid
yeah more like the budget oh the budget
i thought you meant like we're gonna get
50k to film this morning no they're
yeah no but they were like because like
my budgets were like 20 like martians vs
goblins with the game and tyler the
creator
stuff like that was like 20 25 so they
were like look you know we're gonna set
a cap for you we're gonna basically
you know raise your stock up and i
didn't understand it at the time i was
young and i'm like
i'm never gonna work again you know i
know you will different six months
six months for six months i mean because
because they they i mean
stuff came in but it was all underneath
that and so eventually
you know got to a certain point and then
you know like
yeah we just ran it up you know what i
mean and and they just took care of like
production
and and repping me so like i just had to
take care of being a creative
yeah and so that's when that's what
everybody needs man that's when you run
it up you know yeah no time to [ __ ]
think of all the other [ __ ] just let
me get
my [ __ ] done yeah i mean you know it
comes with its cost and rewards you know
and you have to wait it out which one's
best for you and then it just got to a
point where i just got tired of writing
man
because i was writing on so much stuff
and you don't get everything you might
write 30 treatments and get two or three
or five you know what i mean
and you don't have to write but if you
don't write you're definitely not
getting the job
exactly you know you're not prepared
well not even that like if it doesn't
cross their desk they're not
you're not even in the mix oh gosh it's
not like you have an idea let's have
lunch
no no no it's like hey you know hey
everybody
uh hey all directors here's a song whom
a concern
do you like it yeah but and so my agent
would like weeded down
you know and she said do you like this
and i said yeah how many people are
writing on it and then she would call
the actual commissioner and say how many
people
and then if the budget was low she would
be like matt will write but only if he's
the only one writing
gotcha but that you know so but it just
got tiring so much stuff in the back of
these [ __ ] videos man you don't think
they're many movies
oh absolutely wow i mean you're talking
like prep days full crews i mean uh
grip trucks i mean everything you know
what's the biggest what's the most
biggest budget you had to do for a video
what
what is that what does that look like
that was like that was the the
celebration when i was saying earlier
because chris brown tyga lil wayne wiz
and game and that one was like 220 on
just production ended
well we shot like three days three days
one you know and
30 people on the crew more more than
that what
and we had two you know two cameras two
two um
like you know at the crane yeah with
techno crane and everything
i did my first thing i ever did i did a
commercial for this company
get a great gear and i walked there was
a crane and i walked in
and my part was a guy that sells weed
and pizza from his pizza delivery car
i'm like yo did you guys write this [ __ ]
for me because that's exactly what the
[ __ ] i did throughout
college and uh just seeing people taking
things off of a house like no i don't
like that i don't like that here's the
temperature here dude no you're off
you're off
and then they're on
no i don't like it it's too hot yeah
he's hot put it back
it's the best thing i ever did lock it
down lock it down lock it down lock it
down i learned my lines walked out
walked in
bomb never come out here comes talent
a chef that was making medicated food
it's awesome which is really bad because
everybody got [ __ ] up never had that
but i mean i've had a chef like it was
it was cool i've never experienced
anything more than me at my house like
filming or vlogging doing [ __ ] yeah and
yeah it's getting a lot of like looks
and yeah yeah but
having people there like no i do lights
i do sound like
a sound guy it's like how much easier is
this sometimes it's easier sometimes
it's
for me like for me as the person walking
in i'm like yeah yeah but you that's
the hardest thing you can do you have to
now worry about 50 people and that's
that's another half
like half of the job that you don't see
on instagram just with the picture you
know what i mean and that's that's a big
part of your job i mean there's so much
communication communication learning how
to communicate so if you don't know how
to communicate you're not emotionally
intelligent
you study that you have an idea
not only do you need to communicate it
to yourself and get it out on a piece of
paper now you need to take this
and then give it to each group or each
you know you're the lighting guy i need
to give it to you in the way that you're
going to understand it yeah so that you
can give me what i'm
asking for so you have a crew of certain
people like i've worked with you five
times all five times your problem
sometimes and sometimes i bring in a new
guy like yo i like this this video let's
bring them in or the agent would say hey
or somebody would say hey i just
a lot of times i'll give like younger
kids who who are kind of coming up
you know an opportunity and because a
lot of them will buy cameras instead of
going to film school they'll have a red
camera for 45 50 000
and they can't get on set you know what
i mean so i've done that several times
you know
like okay cool you know um but i still
need to communicate to them and
communicate to them in a way that
they can get it and resonate with them
you know get it back to you yeah because
i can't you know and so
you're you're teaching six different
people what you want
yeah yeah yeah that's a job yeah and no
one thinks about that there's nothing
that's there's so much there's no
tutorials there i saw the director doing
our
commercial thing i'm sitting there like
yo i mean most of your work is doing
things that's probably the a.d
i'm not sure the one that's like like
moving around running oh he was sending
him off
he was sending him off in the direction
there with his pads no nope
start over yep too high and yeah yeah
and i don't even say action i let
my out you know i'll say and he'll say
action
so bomb yeah it's so because it makes
your life easier knowing like you can
handle it's like a [ __ ] uh ant
farming [ __ ] like no we have these
people that do this and they're set
i'm the [ __ ] i'm the queen of the
[ __ ] things but if you don't have the
if you don't have the clarity or the
communication skills it's a disaster
i can imagine and like my early videos i
thought people knew
what i was thinking like why aren't you
moving the light
gotcha and they're like but then you
think why don't you know
to move the light yeah you should be
[ __ ] on it and then you think
they don't know what i want no i didn't
think that for like a couple videos i
was just like
what the frustrating grab the light i'm
grabbing the light i'm all pissed off
the guys were like [ __ ] it go ahead do
my job i got paid ready
do what you got to do bro yep damn and
that was that was not
you know that was well you learned man
of course you had learned you have to
come in and realize that lighting guys
are kind of like this
everybody's like you guys are weird or
this or this it doesn't even matter it's
your job to communicate
to everybody you know because they don't
know what it is that dude so much is
going into these things and i've never
thought about it in the terms of you
your role of
no i got 50 jobs i just have the most
important right here
you're important here to make sure what
i communicate to you is being done
you're the president i mean you're the
you're the oversee i mean
you're the foreman you're you're
basically you know supervisor so damn
dude when you do a movie one day
oh yeah whoa that's gonna be crazy a lot
of that stuff is done
already in pre-production you know like
you're
you've already storyboarded you've
already scouted you've already built
your sets you've already ran through
computer generated shots or whatever it
is that you need to do
and so you know you send away your
actors with their stuff and uh you give
them their backstory give them their
psychology
you need to understand psychology to be
able to get what you want out of the
actors
because you don't tell them to kick in
the door a certain way when they rob the
bank you tell them how they had no money
when they were
five years old or two years old in this
scene you're this guy you just got
dumped you're just doing this
and they're trying to bring out the
emotion of the act the director has so
many jobs
yeah so you gotta and sometimes
sometimes the directors won't even talk
to that
talent just to get them pissed off and
so that they can give us that you know
what i mean
oh absolutely all the time you do
whatever it's it's you know there's a
little there's little things that these
directors probably have and like no no
watch this watch this yeah
but but i mean at the same time you have
to be conscious of it and a lot of
people aren't
over here worrying about 8k it goes back
full circle to earlier man
that's why i study psychology you're
speaking to it's more than uh
how many followers you got what what
what are you shooting in well it's more
than that followers do help you again
i'm saying it doesn't help you in the
fact of being a badass i know it makes
you look like more of an idiot if you
have a huge following and then you
don't know [ __ ] yeah and you gotta you
got the talented actor they're going
are you your crew's going hey are you
just brought in the dp or this you know
this camera guy or whatever
you know to come work with you finally
you got a budget and you don't know a
thing you know you over here sounding
like a you know school girl
bam it sucks you know what i mean does
suck but but it sucks that they're not
open
and i hope that you know some people
will listen to this and open up a little
bit more
i mean dude if if this was five years
ago and i watched this exact thing i
would have had a whole different outlook
on what to do
and for sure exactly i mean it just
depends on what the overall goal is
though
well no your mindset on the back
behind the scenes to what what you said
earlier trying to manipulate people's
feelings and then bring it out that's
yeah five years ago that would have
[ __ ]
whether you're really changed whether
you're vlogging or you're you're doing
anything
you're a brand obviously like you said
earlier you know totally agree believes
that yeah
it's uh you know um and
you're you're doing everything i mean
you're that's that's your job if you
pick up a camera that's what you're
doing yeah even if you're taking a
picture of your friend
you're trying to make them look the best
they can right you're trying to
manipulate that scene a little bit
right and if you're a good friend anyway
yeah no a hundred percent so like when
i'm vlogging myself for something i know
people ask all the time but when i'm
vlogging myself
everything in my background's deliberate
everything behind me is deliberate
the way i start off my words is
deliberate because
it's it's it's just it's how it's how to
how am i gonna make you can i always say
like how do i how do i make the audience
feel this and then right away start
smiling
that's good that's definitely that's
what i learned i mean you you learned
what i learned for
for 120 either for 100 a bra i probably
spent so much money
just making videos out of pocket and
[ __ ] i mean hey that's that's the fun
process it was absolutely
the last 10 years been bombed yeah
that's been fun but that's a lot i mean
you're
you're you're right with me like there's
a lot of people who don't even look at
that and i go
no you realize like the green there is
painted green for a reason the director
picked that you know what i mean or the
production designer they that's that
means something in the movies
oh yeah when i'm watching i'm just
breaking [ __ ] down people don't know
they go no it's just the coca-cola no
it's not
[ __ ] because earlier that fool
was hot it was holding that [ __ ] blah
blah blah
and it's also it's also about like you
know market if you want to get money in
because like
you know we're artists and and it's some
some of the art that we
we create we want to make a little bit
of money or we want to have more money
for our projects so
you need to know where things are at so
that you can uh replace that seven up
with the coca-cola or
if they're going to pay for it i mean
obviously there's nothing i'm conscious
of all that [ __ ] because it makes
it makes sense we were the first ones to
bring a beast by dre into into the
you guys did that yes oh man that's in
every [ __ ] video
ever made yeah no the dope boys um
travis barker game was the first one
they had
they brought it in like a case i was
like handcuffed it was because only
apparently yeah yeah and then we put it
in far east movement and everything
after that
damn far east yo those fools were
massive
oh yeah those are my homies man like
shout out to them like that super dope
i think one of the first times i ever
heard of them was this fly like a g6
yeah i remember that [ __ ] yeah they had
a couple
i almost bought a g6 in college the uh
the the
the car it was called a g6 and i was
like yo it's more expensive because of
this
[ __ ] song yo try to buy a car in
college
don't do it don't buy a new car ever
ever in your [ __ ] life don't
absolutely not absolutely not save that
money
all bad dude um so like i said i was
going through everything
astonishing as number i just want to
make sure out of all the videos you've
done
uh accumulative 10 billion billion
[ __ ] views
absolutely i mean yeah like that's
unfucking i probably say more than that
that's ridiculous man yeah that's just i
mean
i mean i've done like five i mean i've
done
a lot of work i mean from the you know
all sides of the spectrum
so it's just uh it's not like yo
i'm [ __ ] tight it's more of people
have watched the [ __ ] i've thought in my
brain it came out how i wanted 10
billion times
yeah i know yeah it doesn't make you
feel like [ __ ]
sick but it's more like thanks yeah yeah
i mean i put my work in
i mean it wasn't easy you know and i
worked seven days a week for 10 years so
like
it's cool that's what you get that's
what you get when you put that work in
you
know
so it's just it's like i know you
probably do it you go back like
that was six months ago when that video
came out down i remember when i was
posting i was getting it ready and going
i was gonna be sick
and then you go back and go do you do
you think like that like and yeah in
phases
yeah absolutely i mean it's all project
yeah i go basically what i did
in that month yeah that was a february
oh all right sometimes it feels like
it's right there and like it was like
yes you know two years ago
oh [ __ ] i do that every day in my life
damn you know what i mean and i look i'm
like at least i look the same
yeah i know shout out to shout outs i
mean there must be something in in the
entertainment or in the video it's the
we do that's true it's the wee house man
i'm just telling you i
remember when i shot with uh you know
i'm really good friends with like uh be
real cyprus hill denmark all these guys
so
i remember oh damn right yeah [ __ ] with
him yeah demick's my boy like where's my
roommate he's the one who introduced me
to the to the
other crew [ __ ] out of here i mean i do
i mean he was my roommate for
like i you know you know i probably met
you before then right oh yeah bro like i
mean i've been to the studio with
denmark a couple times at the studio he
was at i've been to a few
with x i mean it was exhibits it was at
the yeah that's where uh
first time i ever drank hennessy oh it's
crazy yeah i mean
i went to iraq with him damn me in the
exhibit in denmark
i mean i've known it he was the one who
introduced me to that other crew that i
was telling you about in the
studio when i was a director and he was
and there was a rapper that introduced
me to the guys who were
stem right yeah that was when i first
got here before right when i met ski
yeah
uh i started [ __ ] him in dizzy disney
this is my guy
yeah i did all the last videos no [ __ ]
yeah
yeah this is my homie i [ __ ] with him
heavy yeah he's tight yeah
people really good people yeah every
everybody in the still moving [ __ ] is
[ __ ] dead how about everybody i mean
yeah yeah he uh i didn't
even smoke weed and i invited them to a
weed event
and i was here trying to pass hops and
these i didn't
[Music]
um just the weed [ __ ]
okay i think i met him through the weed
[ __ ] i met dizzy uh you guys do like
shops and [ __ ] too
yeah yeah uh i mean i just do so much
social media i get delete
i'm in my 23rd account yeah yeah i get
deleted
you're like oh get twenty thousand it
got deleted oh that one yeah that was
that was just one day [ __ ] it dude
that's okay but yeah no no
yeah big flip it's just it's it's that's
fine it's unreal man
for me i all the videos that i did were
for other people so like i never and
anytime i got to my own [ __ ] i'd be like
dude i'm so tired by this point i'm like
yeah i don't want to be like hi welcome
to mad alonzo you know what i mean i'm
like dude
i do it for my friends i'll do it for
their youtube system yeah so people are
like you don't have this much views i'm
like yeah bro i'm not on my own [ __ ]
youtube
yeah you know exactly like you would
know me by now like you know what i'm
saying like i'd be everywhere you know
but
yeah but like that 40 seconds we were
talking about the connection of how to
bring it out
bro that's the [ __ ] people need we
didn't need to have any of this other
conversation just like 40 yeah that 40
seconds was
like if you're gonna listen to anything
yeah i'll put a timestamp says [ __ ] the
rest of this
no but for real that's it for me when i
was if i was 22 again i heard that
i would have been progressing faster
hopefully hopefully it uh i hope i hope
[ __ ] out there
take that into consideration is you just
got knowledge dropped on your head
so [ __ ] hard uh you know i love it
man no i
sincerely it's like it's there it's
something i'm going to remember
later i tried i liked that i've tried to
uh you know to get it out
plenty of different ways i did a master
class you know i tried to hammer
like when you're teaching people yeah
yeah yeah yeah you know what i mean nice
yeah i've done it i've done it all you
know so i i did i did a couple of them i
did one for a
lighting company we had people driving
from mexico we had people driving from
iowa
and i'm like wow i'm walking into this
thing going there's a line all the way
outside you know and i'm like
damn i'm telling you there's a lot of
views
out there that don't have their
direction yet and in five years they're
gonna go no
i watched the mad alonso i went to his
master class and then [ __ ] steer
like like the [ __ ] marty did uh what
was it that
changed your [ __ ] changed your uh
what'd you do that you you went to a
club oh peter mc you watched the prp
and yeah i started going i'm just
watching youtube but then it was the
full-time film full-time filmmaker sorry
oh yeah
that's what it's called yeah yeah yeah
that one that'll do what's his name
what's his name parker
parker yeah yeah yeah yeah but you see
him saying like if you didn't have that
you would have
would have delayed you five years four
years see but
this show this podcast right now that
might help out some 15 year olds
i hope it does that dad was recording
his [ __ ] that's why i was like that's
why i come on
yeah there's so much that you could just
existing
help out somebody that you didn't even
realize i tried to do the parker thing i
just couldn't i couldn't do it
it's just cool man i can do it
consistently like you know yeah but you
also you gotta remember your brand is
how what you could do and make other
people look yeah that's what
that's what i realized you know if you
had three of you yeah you could make
your own youtube
yeah you could do these master classes
every [ __ ] week i tell people like yo
it doesn't work man it doesn't it
doesn't work for what you need to do to
stay on the top and keep going keep
going
for where i'm at you know i don't even
worry so much about the top like i'm
talking about like
yeah no on top of my [ __ ] yeah i mean
you know yeah and so you
you know you rediscover that as you
continue going on and uh
you know i'm happy to be here with you
right now this is the top top of uh top
of the mountain man and
appreciate i'm excited i'm excited for
you know everything you have coming up
you know what i mean
i'm stuck this year has been sick i
heard about that i was like okay
it's rolling man that's good man that's
really good because this time has like
really created
a you know a really really strong lane
for for some you know what i mean and
if you're capitalizing on you're running
bro yeah and that's
you know like it's you have all eyes on
you like there's a lot of
you know a lot of people watching
content you know what i mean like the
numbers are just going up so
yes and so like you guys did the perfect
timing you were ready to go you're
already a professional
you got the man to make the legend over
here just just running numbers
[ __ ] making it work and that's just
like that's i mean the timing couldn't
be better you know what i mean so it's
all
it just goes to show like all that work
was it's not for nothing all those
years of struggling working at u-haul
was not for nothing right and that's and
anybody out there listening if you can
endure those just endure that you have
to but you have to have a vision though
you can't just endure it for nothing
don't endure it for the likes or endure
for the picture because you go get it
come on i said i'll give you a picture
you have to go back to your job and you
just you know what i mean yeah it ain't
worth it you know
no no it's it's if you can hold on that
long
and be bro i have been [ __ ] bro i
mean i was making so much [ __ ] money
selling packs and then i went to
i'm good i'm gonna send you to my friend
and then i'm watching
ten thousand dollars a week go away like
i mean how those prices
have the prices changed ah they are what
i wish i had
back when i was selling weed the prices
right now all right check this out
for everyone out there listening [ __ ]
you if you're one of these people
so i don't sell weed no more i know
everybody in this industry i know the
black market people i know all i mean i
sell drugs the prices when everybody had
no money during covid and they had no
job
drug dealers decided tax more packs that
i was getting
for 32. yeah yeah can you take you want
to take a guess how much they were
at the end of this year no seven five
seventy five hundred dollars for one
pound of [ __ ] weed
in california it made me so i
sincerely stopped supporting certain
growers after i heard their [ __ ]
problems listen to the streets to the to
the street ten bands right now for the
same pack
if you want it at all after retail ten
[ __ ] thousand dollars my homies
paying 8k for every pe he's rich but
even three two though is i mean that's
the thing that's pretty nice
you gotta be shipping [ __ ] if you're
buying at eight you can't you cannot
you can't make any money i'm so glad i
stopped selling when i did that you're
gonna be shipping like
you have to be shipping at least but if
you're getting them for seven five you
just made five bands on two pounds if
you shipped it and it didn't get there
or not you got your money
yeah i mean yeah doesn't matter though
yeah people are desperate too because
they
they got no money right now so it's like
we were sorry about them stimmys
that's a [ __ ] cute that's an ounce
right now
a couple of blunts i mean me personally
i paid 500
american dollars for an ounce last month
[ __ ] it was fire
but i had to try this certain brand from
a certain grower yeah yeah yeah
and after i smoked a gold this is some
of the best we ever smoked i'll pay 300
bucks
after that you can suck my dick yeah
right for a 500
[ __ ] house i'm not in new york dude i
mean yeah
yeah that's it you're a kind of sword
you're you know you're for me i'm
i just been a wheat as long as it's like
you know not some trash dirt that you're
just like stomping on and you're putting
it
yeah i'm straight you know what i'm
saying like i wish i wish i could like
it's just it's not i get it i get it
yeah i wish i could i got a lung
infection like five years ago
and it's certain we just [ __ ]
infection i was smoking weed that mold
inside bud rot wow i didn't know what
else
i i didn't even know we could get oh
yeah you ever see
furry [ __ ] on your wheels yeah i thought
that was just like that [ __ ] away well
that was just the crystals don't you see
it getting rid
of that [ __ ] bruh nope that's why people
get lung infections damn yeah that [ __ ]
serious i couldn't breathe i couldn't i
had to go to the doctor for like six
months straight
wow like it really hurt i couldn't
that's common it sounds like it's pretty
common yeah i had it five years ago and
i've never been the same how does it
i mean how does it get moldy it was just
the moisture being in a bag
maybe you had spider mites maybe you uh
you sprayed it with something and it
just molded over time
damn you left it out my mom might be
smoking weed she found like five years
ago like i found this little nugget i'm
like i know i got to tell you
it's it's serious though no i know i i
get it serious it's serious you gotta be
careful that i gotta do a [ __ ] video
on that [ __ ] yeah absolutely
i'm like that's a i've never heard of
that called pm powder mold
never heard about a mildew never heard
of it is that new is that something
that's always been around since
people just thought it was frost that's
what i'm saying i was like look at those
crisps
the crystals are there cool i know but
like you know what i mean like it looks
like you threw a little flower
in a certain spots that was cocoa puffs
[Laughter]
you wanna buy some weed yeah man but
yeah
that's crazy that's this this is the way
it works but yeah that's the that's how
the pounds went up man
wow that's that's nuts yeah it's really
sad man it's really sad
you can make i mean oh you can make a
lot of money
i got a company coming out next month i
won't talk about it yet but i'll tell
you after
it's gonna change how you buy weed for
the rest of your [ __ ] life
hey you heard it first i'm telling you
you're gonna go that's not real
it's [ __ ] i believe it i believe it
all is straight
total recall here of [ __ ] weed
evolution and [ __ ]
it's like you know the time is next yeah
in a year
that's how i feel oh yeah i'm stoked
though that's you know
yeah you give it back to your face like
you you know you're you're right
the best thing is the customers get
wholesale prices
dude i need that little yeah i need a
little dj horn
official right now i'm saying something
yo i bet you marty has that button
hey i got on my phone oh [ __ ] really
well i keep that thing on my lives i
just be going dude
oh but wait like you're doing lies on on
instagram youtube [ __ ] yeah but then i'd
be on my i have my computer i just happy
just
what are you doing in your lives talk
[ __ ]
answer questions yeah you sound like me
he talk [ __ ]
yeah i try to like you know just talk
keep the dm's open for the ladies
oh wait but the dude's always blown
oh you know it is what it is you know
yeah
i'm sorry that was so blatantly honest i
loved it there you go you know those
dudes just be flooding my [ __ ]
flooded my ship yeah what's up man i got
a [ __ ] polaroid camera can i hey the
funniest [ __ ] though is when they're
like hey can you send this beat to like
bieber i'm like yeah oh sure no problem
absolutely people
he actually says he wants to be your
best friend and will you be on mtv with
him
hey but hey it's like i get you trying i
get it i get it
there's better ways to do it you gotta
tell me twice yeah but then again that's
the new i passed on my mixtape
it's a yo dm trash
yeah but we all started somewhere yeah
we did we got music you listened to
um everything until i was like 18 it's
only oldies and like doo-wop
like all these like what like motown uh
yes motown doo-wop uh
like little anthony kind of [ __ ] oh
that's like real that's like 50s or 40s
yeah 50 60s right yeah 5060s um
classic rock only besides that he has
like a lot of like
led zeppelin and pink floyd [ __ ] that's
like my mom yeah
yeah that's what i'd listen to into
eleanor rigby
oh yeah the beatles yeah good that's all
that's all good [ __ ]
i love that [ __ ] your mom sounds badass
yeah she sounds tight as [ __ ]
and she's mexican like she's like that's
shocking me right and the fact that she
likes weed it just
doesn't even make sense i never knew
that was like a thing like that oh yeah
i might ask her about this oh yeah yep
she's gonna be like oh yeah i'm shunned
oh my god you said you said that on
youtube
for real like with my family yeah i tell
you it's just like
it's like that it's like a it's like a
white dude telling you who he voted for
it's like yo you don't do that [ __ ]
they don't ask that [ __ ] don't even
bring it up marty doesn't count
raising count he doesn't care about
politics but the guys that do give a
[ __ ]
um but yeah no no just dude and now it's
everything man i listen to
all underground i listen to some
mainstream now what do you prefer
give me give me what's up what's the
last record you you played in car
the last thing i was playing in the car
was the violent fence but that's like
that's rock okay um before i've been
like
i just been listening to that i love
kodak blacks
okay there you go i just love the
ignorance that man just puts in this
song
like yo i can't even understand
sometimes i love you
i love how [ __ ] real and
authentic that
is it's just it's just i love it but um
i've been just listening a lot of
griselda too lately okay a lot
okay because i never grew up on east
coast [ __ ] ever in my whole life
okay so wait i talked about this earlier
uh my mom was a tupac only person
doesn't [ __ ] and she told me baseball's
true two bucks from the east coast i
know that
mom i know that and she's on baseball
sucks but my whole life that's all i
heard
i didn't listen to big ever nothing
until i was 21 years old wow and when i
played it i got pissed and text her ass
yeah mom what the [ __ ] you hold on
yeah i mean that's common from
california yeah that's on every it's on
my bus
ride to school try to sneak the tape i
had to get the little tape oh no my
mom's very
open with meredith advisory she's
she wasn't very strict with that kind of
[ __ ] she let me watch [ __ ] up movies i
was a kid
all types of [ __ ] but yeah when it comes
to music man
i stick with the right now i like do you
[ __ ] you ever heard of xavier wolf
um no xavier wolf
oh have fun let's drive back
but his [ __ ] you ever hear those songs
that makes you just want to get the [ __ ]
up
oh yeah there it is so that's i mean
it's not like all lyrics
he's not like uh funky homo sapiens you
can't do that stuff no more
no i mean not like i mean if it's just
two
poet two like oh i got you i got you i'm
like yo i want to turn it up give me
some like
no i told you just check out music you
know there's this uh mexican kid
out of houston or san antonio uh
emotional zan
emotional zen emotional zan wow i've
never heard of him i love this kid
i'm gonna check him he's a straight punk
punk looking yeah mexican screaming
mexico screamo [ __ ] wow but he does rap
now
and he sounds like [ __ ] gucci man 10
years ago what
i [ __ ] love this kid so much my homie
ratchet man shout out to ratchman put me
on to him
shout out to rashford you are gone why's
he got aaron carter crying i think they
just
[ __ ] did i don't know why you're
she's crying about oh boy avoid this
why is he crooked i don't know that's
not emotional saying
anyway he got a that's dope i'm just you
got all bro you're gonna really [ __ ]
with it
really [ __ ] with it and there's some
parts where a brand of song comes on
it's just
spanish screaming and [ __ ] that's
interesting i can never really like him
wow he really embraced that southern
[ __ ] rap vibe
wow it's great and the look on his [ __ ]
so could contrast so much that i go
wow you have something here just hang on
to it
can you go back to the first to the to
the all page i just want to see who he
signed to
like right there breakdown [ __ ]
zodiac psycho award records
it's really really [ __ ] good sick boy
oh yeah i don't know any
any of those it's really creepers no no
i'm just very interested like
i love that yeah man like it's it's good
[ __ ] yeah but um
emotional yeah i've just been uh there's
a there's a lot of like
um well for a video do you ever heard of
a guy named joji out of a 88 rising
joji jlji out of 88 rising no idiot
rising like rich brian and all those
four
of course joji is the one i feel is the
is the
artist out of that whole group and it's
not rat it's nothing it's straight
r b i say i'm an r b dude so like oh he
he remember uh uh filthy frank on
youtube nope
filthy frank he was that [ __ ] dude
they used to prank everybody in an
outfit
[ __ ] guy and he used his 10 million
like [ __ ] subscribers and said you
know i don't want to do pranks anymore
i'm gonna go straight into [ __ ] music
and he just one he just hit top 100 on
top 10 on
r b records of the country amazing i
love that
you're really gonna dig this [ __ ]
videos bro that's what uh they're shot
like [ __ ]
commercials or something like this you
must have a little budget then you know
oh they're shot like uh like like he's
on gq
they're very i might have seen them
already but when you when you hear
you're gonna be a little like
yo where's this been and then you see
the videos and they have
their their substance dope it's good
it's like a little mini movies man
damn where's very very [ __ ] good
hell yeah i can't i'm seriously gonna
write this [ __ ] down for you because for
sure you've got to watch this fool's
videos they're so well done
hell yeah and you can tell it's just one
dude in the camera following him but
they're not like
he's talking to you it's it's a movie
going on
dope so you're like the camera's not
there i mean i just love you know
love when they crossed you know
different different boundaries i found
them like two years ago and just
i haven't stopped i [ __ ] love this
fool damn you're a breaking artist over
here yeah i love it i love him he's
he's a big artist over here um i don't
know how the [ __ ] we got on that topic
i just actually what kind of music you
like that's all yeah yeah
oh i was curious well dude i know we've
been here for how long
too long 220 you should go an hour and
10.
oh [ __ ] i'm like this one up two hour
and ten is what we usually do
so damn thank you for sitting here this
long look hey i i can't go anywhere i
ain't got
my tires flat
that does
oh [ __ ] yeah especially when you're on
the come up you sleep on couches and
we're always on the come up there
because as soon as we reach one
where we go are you trying to look for
the next thing so we always
come 100 and you're always willing to
sacrifice a little bit more to get to
that next one so
you know that's a good way to put it too
you are always on the come up
no matter what unless you're just
comfortable and once you're comfortable
expect nothing more from yourself
absolutely i mean you're you're useless
at that point
thank you you're useless like what are
you doing are you contributing you're
not even gonna
meet your own standards at that point
because it's just you're so comfortable
yeah i'm perfection i know you i know
you are [ __ ] i don't even know
it's it's to the point where it's like
crippling almost sometimes it really
sucks
it sucks man it's an extra five hours on
[ __ ] just because i'm like no no no no
i've said i'll do that i've sent stuff
back like i've sent money back sometimes
because i couldn't turn in a project
oh oh so you're just like us yeah if i
don't like and like probably not take
your [ __ ] money yeah because what you
need i don't even show them a half i
don't even show them
after you shot it and i've shot maybe
edited five different versions i never
and the versions were fire i watched
them like a month later i'm like dude
this [ __ ] was so dope but in the moment
like it matters how you feel and you've
watched it so many times it should
oh it doesn't get it it gets so stale
you're like yo this [ __ ] was fire
and then that's why more times ago i
tell people like yo bring somebody over
before like when you're when you're
freaking out bring somebody over send
the [ __ ] out to somebody
because they're gonna pair our eyes yeah
i send it to my dad and my dad always
tells me like
oh that's cool or that sucks because he
has no no like
knowledge of anything there's no the
lights coming in he's not the edits he
just tells me if he likes it or not and
then and that's who you're trying to
appeal to the person that has no
knowledge in what your field is don't
ask your [ __ ] friend who's
you know yeah he does color yeah he does
sound like he's the you know he's
sitting in front of the front of the
class at the film school like hey
i don't really like you know your thirds
are off
but that's what we do and then it's just
it's even more of a
i do it all the time but yeah dude
perfectionist on yourself it's
it's it's a blessing what is the word
it's it's you know what you can do
oh that's what it is you know the more
you learn the more you learn like
the more you want to expand and try yeah
and the more i know i can do like before
i knew i could do sky replacements and
and sky replacement and steady and you
know what
like i can i can make a sky with clouds
or rain or i can do anything oh and edit
yeah i'm saying as soon as i knew i
could like
change the weather i know i heard you
guys i heard you guys talking about
changing the weather
like but as soon as you as soon as you
know you can do these things
it always feels like i'm not doing
enough you know that's that's what it is
and then you try [ __ ] and then it's like
hours and days go by i mean i've i've
been editing since i was
seven or eight like a little guy so i
sit there for 22 hours straight
oh yeah i my longest was 20. long as i
ever did on one video the video was
12 minutes long dude wait as long as
you've ever edited on a video
straight without stopping oh okay i know
i've had something to take 50 [ __ ]
hours oh [ __ ] dude that's
yeah yeah but i'm talking about without
stopping no no i'm good i'm good i've
done like two days
i can't do it man especially when i type
with two fingers i'm
computer illiterate oh see i hit it with
my fingers yeah i just do that
oh really yeah because once you learned
short short you know because i try not
to click i broke my hand and
i broke my hand playing football my
senior year bro and then i got my
i wanted to play so bad because we were
undefeated all this stuff i took my [ __ ]
out
early took my pins out my screws out i
signed the waiver i got casted every
game
and i'm thinking as an 18 year old kid
what am i gonna use my hand
i don't need this and then it's just
every single [ __ ] day
so i try not to click so i try not to
click so i try to i try to do more with
the keyboard
wow yo that's beastly that's a lot
that's a lot it sucks of course but uh
this is so much easier
example you're a champ you're for
busting through that [ __ ] with a broken
hand like that i mean
i mean at this point i don't even you
know i mean it hurts like i
literally took my [ __ ] out and like it
just didn't even heal
but dedication everybody that's nice you
better go break your [ __ ] hand
i wanted to play football i guess my
senior year i had been playing since i
was seven i was like
there's no way i'm not gonna yeah
there's no way not and that's the last
one
that's it bro that's it i could have
went to college though yeah and been
like yo yo yo four straight you've
already got just
bro there's no there's no way done no
matter how good you think you are
[ __ ]
how many how many mexicans are there out
there like even every time i see a
mexican in
nfl i get so excited like two there's
two
uh the guy that plays for the uh he's an
offensive lineman i mean yeah yeah and
there's a there was a
kiko alonso which was mine but i think
he's from spain i don't think he was
mexican but
still i'm counting it brown like yo that
brown kid did it
yo any brown kid over six foot i'm like
your golden place yeah i'm gonna say who
are you
dude your mom cheated on your dad
something happened to their dude because
like they
don't i'm the tallest of my family get
the [ __ ] out of here i swear i'm the
shortest my whole family really
for mexican people everyone's kind of
tall in my family my mom's side
you have some wife my two aunts yeah
well on the mexican side
all my uh oh you know what my grandma
she's born and raised in mexico but
she's for german and portuguese
but she's she's a mexican lady but she's
not mexican no no i'm saying
all her brothers are six five six six
because they're half german have
portuguese
so they got the huge tall jeans blue
eyes and um
[Music]
so my dad and all his uncle well my
cousin agent he's kind of tall for
mexican guy
yeah yeah he's kind of tall he's a
baller though right that's all the shoes
and stuff oh yeah he's [ __ ] he's on
and he's on that she's in that center
basketball playing the fourth oh i
thought you were bothered no he's not my
baller because his shoes are tight
was like yeah he bought he buys crazy
shoes you got them json
no um i mean if you're that tall and you
know you better be
doing something duncan yeah no i have a
cousin six six or six seven
and he's just about to be 17. he's a
[ __ ] monster but he doesn't like
sports
oh but i love sports and they're like yo
you're a little too short but
quarterback oh
[ __ ] and but i was so [ __ ] good at
football that it's just
give him you know [ __ ] you you know that
feeling like rock bro
if i was taller yeah i played
quarterback in in when i was in eighth
grade man that was best year of my life
so fun bro i was throwing rockets yeah
you're like the doug flutie syndrome no
i can only jump
i see i was actually the tallest of all
my friends i went through puberty when i
was in like except
but then they all
i'm so glad youtube wasn't like youtube
wasn't a thing
bro i would have been i would have been
all up in like
like so you would have had four
illegitimate kids what you're saying
i don't know i would have a lot of
embarrassing videos up there because i
actually have them still so i'm like
sometimes i'll watch them with my dad or
i'll send them a picture of something
i'll be like
this this would have been on youtube yet
i would embarrass the whole family you
know i would embarrass you you and
everybody
oh yeah absolutely i mean i was you know
it's bad you know so yeah but you gotta
man that's cool nah it is cool it is
cool
you know one year though you know they
should have let you throw the rock
dude that was good too my mom taught me
to throw football really
i'm super [ __ ] amazing actually i
throw football wow
it's kind of crazy how's your mommy mom
just my dad
my dad wasn't around he was always doing
other [ __ ] yeah my mom's
just a little bit yeah my mom just but
that was a nice
cool dude right my dad's [ __ ] tired
but he's just on drugs yeah my grandma's
a heroin addict
oh [ __ ] yeah dick
wait your grandma wasn't heroin i always
say like you never see an old heroin
addict
no she didn't she didn't make it i know
but she made it to be a grandma
i mean dude we're mac she was 31
[Laughter]
she's a great grandma at 40. yeah
exactly she was like
exactly bro i'm so glad you couldn't
relate to it
but still all right she lasted two
generations doing heroin that's amazing
and her mom was around yeah i know right
that [ __ ] just takes people off
all my all my extended family on both
sides were
you know a dick you know oh really have
addictions yet oh
[ __ ] i mean it's just in the bloodline
you know what i mean then you get trauma
and just
you know poverty and things like that
just it is what
my dad kind of made us you know stay in
you know just kind of keep us you know
somewhat sheltered you know what i mean
just kind of keep us focused on
good [ __ ] though sports you know what
the [ __ ] was going on with the family of
course of course you know that's what
the [ __ ]
i'm gonna be doing yeah so it wasn't
like we weren't with our family we just
i didn't know half the show was going on
until i got older you know what i mean
like it should be absolutely but my
grandma crazy stories my grandma um
she got clean when i was born cause my
dad told her that she didn't see me
anymore because she was babysitting me
and
[ __ ] passing out and so when i was
little and so my dad was like cut that
[ __ ] out or you're never gonna see it
she locked herself in the bathroom and
got clean
damn took five days of [ __ ] the worst
pain ever ever
i know some people have gone through
that i can't imagine you know
honor like on your own you know
jesus a little bit of weight on my
shoulders like your grandma did this for
you for you you better succeed
no one ever said that but yeah did you
imagine your freaking
8th birthday you better [ __ ] kill it
your [ __ ] throw up like you know what i
mean like oh man my grandma was like you
know she was just
like hilarious you just say whatever
like oh she so she
stuck around two years older oh yeah
yeah my grandma passed away until i was
like
in college
wow graduated college she ever hold it
over your head like i could be high hell
but i chose you
hell no my grandma was always into like
bro she'd be chasing the cops
she wanted to go figure out what was
going on over there and so she'd pull up
to the house and fire
she because she wanted to get going
because like you know drugs no more like
she's just and she's just an adrenaline
rush absolutely over here chasing with
the [ __ ] scanner
dude absolutely for real absolutely wow
that's kind of tight throwing us in the
dumpster to go hey get that chair right
there i can i can redo that
oh she was that lady yeah but like you
know stay up all night we would watch uh
cops and america's most wanted and
unsolved [ __ ] saturday bro every john
walsh here
watch all that [ __ ] crazy right i hated
the unsolved mysteries guy though
i hated it hello no we didn't no there's
no ending i
like his voice though i say like really
yeah i don't know i was
so like i don't even know yeah i
remember him with the trench coat oh you
know why because i saw i saw
a kid who got burned all over his face
and i was little little little and i was
traumatized
with his voice and then like whatever it
is i saw and i just got you yeah but my
grandma would just be like shut up get
over here
you're watching this [ __ ] oh yeah
this family's pain you should be smoking
a cigarette but like half in
half out the door but half in the door
like
oh your hand was tight yeah she's like
she at least tried she would smoke
cigarettes and say uh
i gotta i gotta i gotta smoke because uh
john walsh is stretching me out
and so she would smoke every every break
commercial break it was oh
[ __ ] and i realized as i got older i'm
like dude no one's making you sm
smoke now like you you know it's just an
excuse and that's hilarious
that was funny but she'd be like
stressed out like
america's most wanted stressing me out
yo family guys i mean uh
mad tv or saturday night live because
right after that was meant to be
starting live dude
we watched tgif though so i'm a few
years older i'm 35 so like
you know i had like family matters and
like all that same year yeah i watched
all that [ __ ] but after oh yeah mad tv
that
would come already we watched mad tv we
didn't i don't think i really watched
uh snl yeah not too much it's ten to
eleven matches
ten thirty to twelve was that no he has
like a little lemon head
i remember yeah okay i haven't seen that
show and i love that yeah i haven't seen
that it was
though yeah i haven't even seen the
branding in like 10 years oh no they
they shut it down but remember like
will sass oh bobby lee's oh no i
remember everybody just
when he said it i i was like no but then
i'm like oh yeah i remember i remember
yeah absolutely yeah just because it was
like clockwork you know what i mean
it was crazy i mean at least we got a
good exposure to like how to run
programming
because every friday night it was like
boom boom boom boom they kept you there
and whatever you had is to eat with top
ramen
popcorn my grandma would buy candy canes
and smash them and be like all right
here
and just so that she you know we could
eat them all night instead of giving us
one
a little bit of this one yeah she would
make it like it was cool so we thought
it was cool
yeah of course you thought it was time
yeah we were like [ __ ] yeah like nobody
else has candy canes like this
everyone share everyone share pass grab
one and pass grab one [ __ ] it that's the
type but programming you know what i
mean i learned pretty quickly you know
boom boom boom boom
yeah no i totally understand there it
can be no downtime yeah it can't be
yeah no that's not what i mean that's
like branding and like everything that's
what the youtube like that's what it
really does well is like you know people
who are on the same time like who
yeah schedules schedules that you know
that you're not going to miss out can
you imagine sitting down and like
family tgif wasn't there i've said this
before
i said the reason i'm trying to get
these videos out on time the same time
it's because i remember what it was like
when i sit down on sunday and simpsons
are about to come on what would you feel
like if it didn't come on
yeah your day's done you're being pissed
you might not even trust them though
it's the same as the bell and the dog
getting the field it truly is yeah
you're just you're conditioning you know
what i mean yeah but we but
you know we really saw that i mean as
you get older people
began to pick which they wanted to watch
because there was like a bunch of
amazing things to watch
i [ __ ] around with those tv guides
still my grandpa worked at the spot that
made tv guides what about the
that was that was before
oh i missed it damn two more minutes and
you'll [ __ ] be back yeah
like i mean i don't know who can you
know if you don't know what that is look
it up
that was the worst channel i'd get there
and go but you had no but i know but you
had you you had to
but no my grandpa worked he made tv
guide so there was dope
snacks everywhere i never got those
things yeah my gran that's a one like
little thing my grandpa did that was
like yo this is sick i know what's going
on before everybody else does
i thought it was ty i was getting all
the collector's ones he thought they
were worth money they weren't with [ __ ]
he made it why would he be worth money
like you made in merced where was he
getting the
the information from they make they make
the tv guys at his work
oh so he just take the new ones well he
said he was making him so i thought he
was like no no no no
he made him out yeah yeah yeah hell yeah
so he would like just take the new ones
like oh this new collection
oh he was that guy bro it was that guy
my grandpa was badass
same with the [ __ ] he told you the
tapes yeah you tape every [ __ ]
nightmare yeah yeah yeah he's always at
work so he comes home he goes nope i got
this this this this ain't gonna work in
five hours all right cool
yeah that's dope yeah this game was cool
man it was a it was like you're a
knighters fan
are you
i have a love hate but yes i mean who
was there when you became a fan spread
far he just dissed me one time when i
was a kid so i just
hold it over his head for the rest of my
life and i want to my goal in life is to
get rich and famous enough to where i go
brett farm
you dissed me in san francisco for real
i was like
you did you because this is a lot of fun
i was 11 and i have brett favre
everything you can possibly think of i'm
a far fanatic
i love it i wrote a [ __ ] i got
assigned
i got i got assigned a pick a state in
fourth grade i picked wisconsin
all my facts were about backers kind of
f
i had no credible [ __ ] information
farved
yeah so anyway i wouldn't leave you with
[ __ ] hours in the rain at the san
francisco [ __ ] packer game
my grandpa's like i'm not waiting
because he just looks like the player
when the players come out he's an ender
fan he's like
waiting out here for brett warf and he
went sat in the truck three [ __ ]
hours
me two old ladies they were singing a
song in the made up about him with with
signs
i had the whole outfit on and this
[ __ ] was like 10 feet away
and he purposely didn't look at us
from the [ __ ] locker room all the way
to the bus we're standing by the bus
like waiting i met bubba frank donald
driver
they were cool as [ __ ] oh yeah i
remember those years yeah i'm looking at
him like
oh oh my god i don't like why did they
lose
[ __ ] one oh that's when my grandpa
was pissed he wanted to wait the car
cause
he's lost garcia yeah and he literally
did
this one the ladies next to me were
white
so it's not like it was a race thing
he's just a dick yeah you know
straight up just dissed us all in the
old ladies
with their signs what year was that
though because i know he was taking
pills
like that he was on the pills yeah okay
so yeah that was the the pill
the year of the pill yeah i mean i
remember that so like you know i mean
far
we don't hold you i all the way
accountable i you know
but i understand if you were [ __ ] up i
don't i don't understand
but you definitely also show and get on
if you can win a football game in the
nfl on pills you can take a left and go
thanks guys hey you said it you heard it
it's true though but that's all that's
all so no i grew up
hey brett favre please send us a uh ford
jersey
yep i have mine still no i sent you one
signed sorry for that day
i got it i got your rookie card
[ __ ] damn that's your atlanta
card got your [ __ ] i got everything
wait you have your cards from like back
in the day
i have an extensive collection of cards
like newer ones because i know it came
back i stopped in like
when i was about 14 i stopped buying
them but i got a
i could buy a house off them i have a
crazy but they weren't worth anything
for like a period of time they're worth
a lot i got this i know but like taking
oh oh no no i had the becky book
i know i have the beckets but yeah i
brought them all down i knew i know i
knew my cards were worthless
but like as they but like as they got
more expensive and now they are because
now it's cool again but i'm saying there
was a time where they were oh where they
were [ __ ]
that's what i'm saying well the value
went down a lot dude a lot a lot but i
have like
ones that i used to buy i'm that kid
they were all the plastic cases
with uh the drill guns yeah you're just
like me absolutely
i got everything
i'll sell them right now anybody got
foreign
mystery boxes that they send to you just
buy it you know what i mean just
somebody no
somebody's gonna [ __ ] make us get a
killing
i got some [ __ ] in there that and even
comic book stores like
what oh you got comics in there too no
i'm saying even though it's the comic
book store that's why you buy all my
cards in the comments
like even they'll be like yo you want to
sell that [ __ ] like no
i know it'll be worth it i uh i remember
the last one i'll talk about the i
remember looking at the cards and going
patriots just picked this guy up i'm
gonna put his rookie card in the case
did you see it just
tom brady rookie card just sold for 400
bands yeah right it was something great
i have the other one
it's still worth 27. but i remember
saying like he's going to be good they
just picked him up and i put him in the
seal this is going to be
amazing i was drunk as [ __ ] with my
friends two years ago and i go
no i got football cards i looked and go
tom brady
i haven't looked at these in 10 years
and i have this [ __ ] original no
beard tom brady card but i got like four
jerry rice
yeah i got rookies like a bunch of steve
yeah everybody
i got steve young's in the buccaneers
buckingham's outfit right yeah the tops
it was the top she's like green with the
green on the outside like that
yeah yeah yeah i know exactly what card
i got two of those i got a remake and
then the original
that was the no that was there was two
there was the tops and then there was
the what was the one with the white with
the little like
banner had like a little banner on the
top where they said their name i don't
remember what it was
but they were like rookie cards they
were all kind of looking i know exactly
what card you're talking about he has no
helmet on he's got kind of yeah
yeah yeah with the curly hair yeah yeah
absolutely no exactly yeah it's crazy
yeah it's coming right back it's coming
back i didn't know until somebody told
me me either i saw lucky has a show i
was like what the [ __ ] cards are
they're back i looked up some of the
prices on my [ __ ] i know bro
yo it's like what rolls royce okay hey
but you better sell them before they get
because i'll sell them all right now i'm
just saying because i'm done
carrying stuff around my life i just
don't know yeah i'm i'm a
consistent like i don't know i gotta get
it away from me bro i keep
toys in the little toy shelf that i love
my whole life and that's my clutter yeah
we're gonna but i'm actually just
organizing
yeah yeah i'm just i just i can't but
i'm just saying like i could see that
that that just facing out real quick
after this people
and how crazy is it they went they shot
up when nobody had no money dude i mean
just
yeah i just was like wait what cards
who's but
who's got money all the same people that
had money now like oh you guys are poor
right now
yeah but like i was just i don't know it
tripped me out like i still haven't
bought in i haven't even checked my old
cars i was like my dad's just gonna
check
you're my dad's like yo you know yeah
we're banging up there
because he bought a bunch of these old
old cards really really good condition
from a yard said that we're all
baseball like i mean i'm talking like i
don't even know there's so many baseball
cards
i don't know baseball either why but
they're from like i mean they're little
cards they're like this big i mean
they're from like the 50 like when they
yeah it's
they're old old old old really yeah
we're banging up there
am i like not like you i know tom
brady's but like you might
you might yeah i'm telling you because
tom brady was not a very like
not like they stopped around that time
because that was like 90
i stopped at 2002 2003. yeah see i was i
thought way before that because he got
picked up in 2000
or 2001. yeah no i was like back when
the drew bledsoe days remember that i
had jew bless those cars he was always
i could always tell he was a good player
because even if i shot even if i didn't
watch i could just see how much it was
on the stats 4.95
oh the becky book man i haven't i never
read the stats though oh
i just wanted to care how much they were
i did all that [ __ ] probably the
holograms i had the holy grails from
denny's
from uh oh yeah yeah
[ __ ] danny's over here playing me
think i'd have some good [ __ ] i
collected some of those i collected some
[ __ ] uh
nascar ones yeah yeah remember the boat
jackson
golds i have a full
yeah you gotta like rip it to get to
even see the card or whatever yeah
yeah see you you know about all this
[ __ ] because that's that's usually you
only know if you [ __ ] with cars oh no we
were i mean that's
you know what i mean i'd be reorganizing
them and they're all my shit's my team
oh yeah player and team and then put in
an order of importance yeah right
no of course you know 450 cards i had a
card i had a card sale when i was like i
don't know like 11. no one ever no one
came but
i stayed up all night and priced out all
the cars i put them all on the table and
you thought you're gonna bank i always
thought that too like i was buying a
house
i was like i was like i'm buying a house
container i don't know i was literally
buying a house off this [ __ ] yeah no
it's
the only thing i kept throughout my
whole life and my [ __ ] michael keaton
batman toy that's it that's cool
than that but yeah [ __ ] yeah card talk
what's up nerds i know i know dude i was
like
i could i couldn't believe it and it's
like it's like a cool thing you know
like ski has it on his he's
actually worked pokemon's back man oh
that's pokemon cards
i know i know that's i had a set of
winnie the pooh cards from disney
that sounds sicker than [ __ ] pokemon
cards dude i don't i've never seen him
before
since you know only set that i have so
probably something remember x-men
the x-men pack dude yes i have something
else
right here downtown you know the uh like
the mission the mexican part here
downtown where it's all old school
yeah this man down there sold me a pack
each pack was two dollars
and i bought as many as he had he's got
sick ass old 90s toys some of the bubble
gum still
in the [ __ ] he just i mean because dude
it was worth
nothing back then but even it's not
worth nothing i just love it
i know right but i'm saying even like
five years ago even like two years ago
where's nothing
bro past eight months just exploded it's
crazy anybody out there that wants to
buy some [ __ ] cards yes
1 800 cards r us for real but don't
because then someone's going to get
upset he's got
bangers dude um i would love to sell
them but we'll see
we'll get to that we should do a show
and you show all your cards oh my god
get robbed
i thought that tom brady someone's gonna
rob my ass you're ready to go let's get
that straight let's go
how sad it is that that's a real thing
no not for cards a hundred percent
people steal shoes at shoes drops but
but shoes choose are status
cards those people aren't wearing the
shoes they're selling them that's true
the cards they're they're not card for
that they say how much are these worth
look them up on the internet same thing
with the looting happen like yo it's
just still [ __ ]
don't sell this [ __ ] someone's gonna
break boxes bruh
that [ __ ] was like hey go in that one go
in that one i'm not gonna say who i know
somebody that was uh
taking advantage of that and just going
store to store pharmacy to pharmacy
i mean whoa get it if you're gonna do it
but damn
if you're going to do it then i mean
whatever but i don't know yeah
i don't advocate that and i just you
know i i have empathy once
once i developed empathy because i was a
psychopath for a long time but once i
developed empathy like i'm like damn
what about the owners though
that could be course what if they're
hella broke barely making they couldn't
afford insurance this month
and they couldn't no most of them didn't
have insurance that's crazy so that's
crazy thinking so i think about both
sides you know what i'm saying of course
you have to but
you have to man but you're not thinking
about both sides with the not those
people
i can't steal but they also too bad yeah
i saw my mom's uh like my mom's not
wedding ring but a ring her mom gave her
to give away to my to my
girlfriend that's different bro fifth
grade bro you're a little boy that's
kind of awesome bro it was like you know
it was like it was like
did you get it back never oh what are
you doing
little girl jesus whatever that was a
scrub i was a scrub
but in high school yeah i smashed her
[Laughter]
he laughed slightly looked to the left i
don't know if that was i don't know i
don't know
i don't know what side of my tail is but
some ladies know out there
shout out to you guys because you'll be
like oh he looked to his left whatever
that is whatever that means they know
i don't know i just thought you were
like well maybe i did yeah i mean i felt
bad though man i crushed that's the only
thing i've ever alluded
the only thing i ever looted i wouldn't
because she gave me one
and i lost it and i was like [ __ ] i need
another one she wasn't in the shower or
something so i just
banged on it yeah i banged
fifth grade stealing rings stole my
mom's [ __ ] gave to a girl that
didn't deserve that [ __ ] never man
yo i was a sim real quick i had a red
pill right then and there
oh [ __ ] i was like all right things will
never be the same
yo dude um [ __ ] dude i can't believe how
long it's been yeah
27 hours marathon yo i think we're the
longest stream
ever it's just been a long time dude um
i know we talked about a lot yeah we did
it
no it's fun i love it man i love that
it's so relatable because
you've said the same [ __ ] that i've been
saying my whole life like
i started speaking spanish i heard half
of that [ __ ] i was like all right cool
yeah yeah
cool we're fine yep yeah because it it
like i said it always matters like this
is a podcast cool
i also want to enjoy a [ __ ]
conversation with somebody and not go
so what do you do hey this guy's a
[ __ ] dick
like i don't ever want to do that [ __ ]
yeah no you can't you mean you i can't
and plus me
get the [ __ ] out yes yeah it's not like
i gotta
like make sure first because i don't
want to be that's why we just don't talk
in that way because there ain't
nothing to say yeah not many to talk to
you like
that's that's saying with me and you're
from but i moved down your five years
ago
i have a couple friends five years i
have a couple
other than that culture shock was it
culture shock though [ __ ] no i moved
downtown because i was like nah i want
to get into busyness because if i like
it
i can handle it i'll stay i was fine
that's cool because someone said small
as [ __ ]
oh yeah so i had to handle it [ __ ] yeah
i'm fine dude everybody's attracted to
my family i want to drive i'm
i'm good man yeah um so everybody thank
you for chilling with us through [ __ ]
76 topics
i appreciate the rant i love that you
rant too because i do and i always feel
bad
um thank you so much where can everybody
find you on social just matt alonso
everything my lounge
everytime alonzo you know everything man
i was looking at it
dude there's a lot of work on there yeah
yeah i've been updated in about five
years
okay so i looked at i got 5 billion i
could have swore i just said
10 yeah yeah that's why i looked at it
you've doubled up all right i haven't
touched that thing forever yeah it's
crazy because like just one video that i
did a couple years ago like already
surpassed yeah yes the roof [ __ ] yeah
it's awesome man that's
to be the kid that your your dad was
just filming not liking it so now you're
not mom and dad come on the set i want
to show you these cranes and the [ __ ]
we're getting done dude they were
flipping out
get the [ __ ] out of here my dad just
real quick before we ended
there's a funny story my dad came to the
first video shoot and uh one of the pas
decided to make himself the oil boy
there was no such thing as an oil boy
but he
all the girls got lined and he just
my dad's like what is that i'm like i
don't know he's like made it up yeah and
my dad was just
my dad you can't be it was hilarious
because like you know you never i've
never seen that [ __ ] either you know
what i mean and then they all sat
on the leaning against a wall in a
mansion that we we got for free through
a hookup
happened to be like some gold leaf paint
that they just brought in from italy or
some [ __ ] it all came off
they destroyed it with their asses with
their asses
yo that's like some [ __ ] soul glow
coming to america [ __ ]
dude yeah all over your body and you're
just like hey what do we hang out at you
know
video show girl damn you know shout out
to the videos shout out to the video
show girls
yeah matt alonso everything bro matt
alonso everything ladies hit me in the
dm you already know what it is
youtube too do you do that too
not for them to hit you up what's up on
yeah yeah everything's bad alonzo you
can find me in the comments whatever you
need to do
all right i'll put you in this uh link
will be in the description for
everything
thank you for the conversation man thank
you thank you for that honestly man i'm
telling you there's gonna be kids out
there that watch this [ __ ]
that resonate it's good it's really
gonna hit because like i said
i'm already doing this [ __ ] and i'm like
that's good [ __ ]
so thank you for dropping the knowledge
thank you for taking the time to come
out here i know you got a flat [ __ ]
tire that sucks
we'll get it fixed but that [ __ ] out you
know go get it done
thank you so much for hanging out with
me thank you for having me i appreciate
it thank you so much
um all right i'm gonna close it out guys
thank you so much for hanging out with
us this has been another episode of the
dope as usual podcast
thank you so much for hanging out for
through the rants all right guys if
you're driving please be careful please
drive safe if you're at home smoke it
the [ __ ] up i'll see you guys next week
have a dope ass day nice dude oh yeah
thank you no thank you i can't believe
we did another 250
250. yeah we just ran that thing huh
[Music]
perfect
[Music]
perfect
[Music]